THE SENATE COMMITTEE. ON
INSURANCE WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE
CORVETTE NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHER
INTERNET HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE ALSO HAVE
PRESENTATIONS FROM SEVERAL
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS. FOR REMARK
PART REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE
MAKE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
THIS WILL GREATLY AID IN
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK I ASK THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT
USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE
IN THE PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE PLEASE
SELECT AND MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING. R. I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN
YOU'RE DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN
BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR
NAME AND THEN YOU'RE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
TWO PHONE LINES. THAT WILL ALLOW
. ALSO FOR TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE UP FOR INDIVIDUALS TO BE
ABLE TO TESTIFY REMOTELY FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 844-291-4185 ONCE
AGAIN. 844-291-4185 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. FOUR SIX SIX
THREE NINE SIX EIGHT ONCE AGAIN
FOUR SIX SIX THREE NINE SIX
EIGHT FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCE THIS
TIME WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE AND OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. FOR TODAY'S HEARING WE
WILL BE HEARING ALL OF THE
PANELS OF WITNESSES ON THE
AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENTS ONCE WE HAVE
HEARD ALL OF THE WITNESSES WE
WILL HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
COMMENT ON THE TOPICS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER
FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THEY CARRIED ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM ALL OF YOU WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING **** CUSTOMARY ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVCE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT
SO ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD TODAY THE COMMITTEE WILL
HEAR FROM SEVERAL INDIVIUALS
WHO ARE WORKING TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA MORE RESILIENT TO
WILDFIRES WITH OVER TWENTY FIVE
BILLION IN INSURED LOSSES AND
BILLIONS MORE IN UNINSURED
LOSSES THE TWENTY SEVENTY TEN
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRE. THE THEN WAS A WAKE UP
CALL TO ALL OF US THAT WE NEED
TO BE DOING MORE TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR HOMES
FROM WILDFIRES THIS CALL IS
BEING ANSWERED BY STATE AGENCIES
INSURERS AND CONSUMER
ORGANIZATIONS AND THIS HEARING
WILL EXPLORE SOME OF THE WORK
THAT IS ONGOING TO FORTIFY
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WILDFIRES.
ARE HEARING WILL FEATURE TWO
PANELS ON THE FIRST PANEL WE
WILL HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE CAL FIRE AND CALLOW E.
S. ON THEIR ROLES IN THE SAFER
FROM WILDFIRE INTEGRATION
PARTNERSHIP WE WILL ALSO HEAR
FROM THE UNITED POLICY HOLDERS
ON A SIMILAR INITIATIVE TO HELP
HOMEOWNERS UNDERSTAND THEIR RISK
AND LEARN HOW TO REDUCE THEM.
OUR SECOND PANEL WILL. DELVE
DEEPER INTO SOME OF THE EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE BEING
DEVELOPED TO REDUCE THE IMPACT
OF WELFARE AND MAKE INSURANCE
MORE AVAILABLE TO CONSUMERS THIS
WILL INCLUDE A DISCUSSION FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
INDUSTRY REPRESENTATIVES AND WE
WILL ALSO HEAR FROM SOME OF THE
COMPANIES DEVELOPING THESE TOOLS
DIRECTLY SUCH AS- ZESTY ARREST
MON MODELER. LYNSEY FIRE SENDS A
MAKER OF FIRE SENSING
TECHNOLOGIES WHILE FAR DEFENSE
SYSTEM A PRIVATE FOURTH OF
MITIGATION EXPERTS EMPLOYED BY
THE INSURANCE COMPANIES TO
PREVENT LOSSES. AND A ON ONE OF
THE WORLD'S LARGEST INSURANCE
BROKERS AND FINANCIAL RISK
MANAGEMENT COMPANIES THIS ROUND
OF PANELISTS IS MEANT TO GIVE US
A QUICK LOOK INTO EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES. BEFORE WE BEGIN
WITH OUR SPEAKERS I WOULD LIKE
TO INVITE THE PUBLIC WANTING TO
PARTICIPATE TO CALL IN NOW.
PLEASE DIAL THE TOLL FREE NUMBER. 844-291-4185 WHEN PROMPTED
PLEASE USE THIS ACCESS CODE FOUR
SIX SIX THREE NINE SIX EIGHT. TO
BE ADDED TO THE QUEUE ONCE AGAIN
WE WILL HEAR FROM ALL PANELISTS
FIRST BEFORE PUBLIC COMMENT. NOW
WE WILL HEAR FROM OUR FIRST
PRESENTER JOINING US TODAY IS
MIKE PETERS AND DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER FOR CLIMATE
SUSTAINABILITY AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE. AND AS A REMINDER
TO ALL PANELISTS TIME IS LIMITED
SO PLEASE KEEP YOUR
PRESENTATIONS CONFINES TO SIX TO
SEVEN MINUTES. A MISTER PETERSON
WELCOME AND YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND GOOD MORNING- GOOD GOOD
MORNING SURE RUBIO BY ST JOHN'S
AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON INSURANCE THANK YOU
FOR INVITING ME TO. VIRTUALLY
CONTRIBUTE BY PRESENTING HERE
TODAY HI MY NAME IS MIKE
PETERSON- W. COMMISSIONER ON
CLIMATE AND SUSTAINABILITY AT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE AND I'M GOING TO SHARE
MY PRESENTATION HERE- SO THAT
YOU CAN. FOLLOW ALONG AS THEY GO.
GREAT THANK YOU. I DON'T. WANT
TO RISK HIS LIFE HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORY BUT IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS WE HAVE TRAGICALLY SEEN
NEW RECORDS FOR LOSS OF LIFE
ACRES BURNED. AND LOSSES OF
HOMES AND BUILDINGS THIS IS A
VERY COSTS AND LOSSES FROM
WILDFIRES IN THE LAST THREE
YEARS HAVE BEEN WIDELY REPORTED
BY RESEARCHERS. THE PRESS AND
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES. TODAY I WAS
ASKED BY THE COMMITTEE TO FOCUS
MY COMMENTS ON THE PATH WE HAVE
CHARTED AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. TO REDUCE WILDFIRE
RISKS AND HOW THAT PLAN
COMPLEMENTS THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS THAT ARE STATE
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT WILDFIRE
RESPONSE AGENTS. WITH HOME AND
COMMUNITY HARDER CRUCIAL TO
REDUCING LOSSES IN SAVING LIVES.
BUT WHAT ACTION SHOULD EACH
HOMEOWNER TAKING HOW SHOULD THEY
BIND TOGETHER WITH THEIR
COMMUNITY TO REDUCE WILDFIRE
RISKS. IN TRUTH MISTER CAR LARA
HAS HELD MEETINGS WITH THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THIRTY
SIX COUNTIES. HE'S HEARD FROM
HOMEOWNERS AND BUSINESSES THEY
DESPERATELY WANT TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND THEIR COMMUNITY.
THE FIRST SIGNS OF A MAP THAT
CAPTURES A SNAPSHOT OF THAT
INFORMATION IN THOSE MEETINGS
AND ENGAGEMENT WITH COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. FOR NEW
HOMES CALIFORNIA IS IMPORTANT
BUILDING CODES RELATED TO
WILDFIRE SAFETY KNOWN AS A
CHAPTER SEVEN A BUILDING CODES.
FOR EXISTING HOMES THAT WERE NOT
BUILT TO THE STANDARDS WE NEED A
CONSISTENT AND CLEAR APPROACH TO
REDUCING RISK. THREE YEARS AGO
LESS THAN 7% OF THE HOMEOWNERS
INSURANCE MARKET HAVE ACCESS TO
INSURANCE INCENTIVES NAMELY
PREMIUM DISCOUNTS FOR HAVING
TAKEN HOME HARDING ACTIONS. IT'S
DIFFICULT INCENTIVIZE BROAD
SCALE WHILE PERMEATION MEASURES
WITHOUT CONSISTENT AND SHE WILL
GUIDANCE TO HOMEOWNERS AND
COMMUNITIES. TO CLARIFY THE
INCENTIVES TO ADAPT OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR MORE INTENSE
HIGHER SEVERITY WILDFIRES
COMMISSIONER HELD THE FIRST
INVESTIGATORY HEARING NO
WILDFIRES IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO I'VE SKEWS ME TWENTY
TWENTY. AND THEN A VIRTUAL
PUBLIC MEDIA WILDFIRE RISK
REDUCTION IN DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY WHICH INCLUDE EXPERTS
FROM CAL FIRE INSURANCE
ACTUARIES THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. AND FROM THE
INSTITUTE FOR BUSINESS AND HOME
SAFETY AND THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONERS. IN FEBRUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE COMMISSIONER
LAUREN ELSE THE WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PARTNERSHIP.
INCLUDING THE DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE AND GOVERNMENT GAVIN
NEWSOM'S ADMINISTRATION.
INCLUDING THE FOLLOWING AGENCIES
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION WHICH WE OFTEN
REFERRED TO AS CAL FIRE. THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH. AND THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION. THE
WILDFIRE MITIGATION PARTNERSHIP
HAVE INTER AGENCY MEETINGS TO
IDENTIFY ALIGNMENT OF PROGRAMS
AND THEN MET WITH CONSUMER
GROUPS WILDFIRE EXPERTS AND
INSURANCE TRADE ASSOCIATIONS TEN
FOR OUR DISCUSSION. ONE YEAR
LATER ON FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE WATER
<c.magenta>ITIGATION PARTNERSHIP ANNOUNCED</c>
FAVOR FROM WILDFIRES A NEW
FRAMEWORK FOR WILDFIRE SAFETY
THAT WILL HELP SAVE LIVES AND
PROTECT EXISTING HOMES AND
BUSINESSES. THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
ALL THESE AGENCIES HAVE BEEN
ESSENTIAL AS HAS THE
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM CONSUMERS
CONSUMER GROUPS RESEARCHERS
OUTSIDE GOVERNMENT AS WELL. THIS
INCLUDING A POLICY HOLDERS WHOSE
WILDFIRE RISK AND ASSET
PROTECTION PROPOSAL WAS TRUE A
TREMENDOUS CONTRIBUTION TO OUR
PROCESS IN THE BOX FROM UNITED
WHOLESALERS OR TESTIFY LATER ON
THIS PANEL. ALSO THE WORK OF THE
INSURANCE INSTITUTE FOR BUILDING
FOR BUSINESS AND HOME SAFETY I.
B. H. S. THE DEVELOPER WALTER
PREPARED HOME PROGRAM. ALIGNS
WITH THE SAFE FROM WILDFIRES
FRAMEWORK. I'M NOT GOING TO WALK
THROUGH THE FRAMEWORK AND PUT UP
SLIDES THAT THEN MAYOR- WHAT I'M
GOING TO VERBALLY SAY. YES THAT
WAS THREE THREE LAYERS OF
PROTECTION. FOR THE STRUCTURE
FOR THE IMMEDIATE SURROUNDINGS
AND FOR THE COMMUNITY AS A WHOLE
. FOR PROTECTION THE STRUCTURE
THE SAVER FROM WILDFIRES FOR
INFOSYS FOCUSES ON A CLASS A.
FIRE RATED ROOF. MAINTAINING A
FIVE FOOT NUMBER RESISTANCE ZONE
AROUND THE HOME INCLUDING
FENCING THAT FALLS WITHIN THAT
FIVE FEET. A NON COMBUSTIBLE SIX
INCHES AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
EXTERIOR WALLS. AMBER AND FIRE
RESISTANT BANDS UPGRADED WINDOWS
ENCLOSE THE- TO REDUCE WILDFIRE
RISK IN THE IMMEDIATE
SURROUNDINGS THERE FROM
WILDFIRES FRAMEWORK IDENTIFIES.
VEGETATION AND DEBRIS FROM UNDER
DAX REMOVAL OF COMBUSTIBLE SHEDS
AND OTHER OUTBUILDINGS FROM
IMMEDIATE SURROUNDINGS OF THE
HOME TO AT LEAST A DISTANCE OF
THIRTY FEET. AND DEFENSIBLE
SPACE COMPLIANCE INCLUDING
TRIMMING TREES REMOVAL BRUSH AND
DEBRIS FROM THE YARD IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE LAW OR
LOCAL ORDINANCE. WE'RE WORKING
TOGETHER AS A COMMUNITY THE
WATER MITIGATION PART YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED SEVERAL COURT OPINION
WHICH SHE COMMUNICATION ALONG
WITH. A CLEARLY DEFINED
BOUNDARIES AND A LOCAL RISK
ASSESSMENT IN CONSULTATION WITH
THE LOCAL FIRE DISTRICT OR STATE
FIRE AGENCY. AND IDENTIFIED
EVACUATION ROUTE IMPLANTS.
INCLUDE FUNDING SOURCES TO
IMPLEMENT COMMUNITY MITIGATION
ACTIVITIES ANY RISK REDUCTION
GOALS. ONE SUCH EXAMPLE BETWEEN
DESIGNATION AS A FIREWISE USA
COMMUNITY IN GOOD STANDING AS
RECOGNIZED BY THE NATIONAL FIRE
PROTECTION ASSOCIATION AND THAT
INCLUDES HAVING UPDATED RISK
ASSESSMENT IN AN UPDATED
COMMUNITY ACTION PLAN. LOOKING
FOR THE WATER MITIGATION
PARTNERSHIP ALSO IDENTIFIED THE
FIRE RISK REDUCTION COMMUNITY
DESIGNATION AS ESTABLISHED IN
PUBLIC RESOURCES CORD FORTY TWO
NINETY POINT ONE WHICH IS UNDER
DEVELOPED BY THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION. IN
CLOSING I HAVE I HAVE THREE
POINTS I'D LIKE TO UNDERSCORE.
FIRST MAKING COMMUNITIES SAFER
SAVES LIVES AND REDUCES LOSSES.
SECOND BECAUSE RISK DRIVE THE
PRICE AND AVAILABILITY OF
INSURANCE WE REDUCE RISKS. WE'LL
SEE IMPROVEMENT ON BOTH PRICE
AND ACCESS TO INSURANCE FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING WITH
WILDFIRE RISKS. IN THIRD AS A
RESULT OF WORK OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS WE NOW HAVE
SEVENTEEN HOME OWNERS INSURANCE
COMPANIES TODAY AND COUNTING
OFFERING DISCOUNTS FOR HOME
GARDENING ACTION. THESE
COMPANIES REPRESENT 40% OF THE
MARKET UP FROM JUST 7% THREE
YEARS AGO. THE SAVIOR FROM
WILDFIRES PRIMER PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL CLARITY AND
CONSISTENT APPROACH TO
STRENGTHEN SENTENCE FURTHER
MAKING COMMUNITIES SAFER AND
MORE RESILIENT. HAVING
IDENTIFIED THESE POINTS OF
CONSENSUS WE'RE FOCUSING ON
PUTTING THIS FRAMEWORK INTO
ACTION THROUGH PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT
AND EDUCATION INCLUDING DURING
WILDFIRE PREPAREDNESS MONTH IN
MAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
PRESENTATION WE WILL NOW MOVE
OVER TO OUR SECOND PANELIST. WE
WILL INVITE NOW- TO JOIN US FROM
CAL FIRE DANIEL BERLAND
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR CHIEF
OF COMMUNITY WILDFIRE
PREPAREDNESS AND MITIGATION MR
BERLIN YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY. YEAH THANK YOU
AND GOOD MORNING NATURAL REVEAL
ON MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AS
MENTIONED I DO ANYMORE LAND A
CHIEF OF CAL FIRE'S COMMUNITY
WILDFIRE PREPAREDNESS AND
MITIGATION DIVISION AT TODAY I'M
GONNA PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE WITH
AN OVERVIEW OF CAL FIRE'S
ACTIVITIES DURING THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FIRE SEASON-
INVESTMENTS IN OUR FIRE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS INCLUDING
OUR GRANT PROGRAM. AS WELL AS
OUR ROLE IN THE SAFER FROM
WILDFIRE FRAMEWORK THAT MR
PETERSON I'M JUST A LAID OUT OUT
FIRST THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE- OVERGROWN FORESTS AND
PROLONGED DROUGHT HAVE RESULTED
IN UNPRECEDENTED TREE MORTALITY
WITHIN OUR STATE'S FOREST AS
WELL AS AN INCREASE IN NOT ONLY
THE NUMBER BUT THE SIZE AND THE
SEVERITY OF WILDFIRES. IT'S NO
SECRET THAT THEFACTS HAVE LED
TO YEAR AFTER YEAR SIGNIFICANT
AND RECORD BREAKING WILDFIRES IN
THE PAST FIVE YEARS- CALIFORNIA
HAS EXPERIENCED NOT ONLY THE
LARGEST WILDFIRES IN OUR
RECORDED HISTORY BUT SOME OF THE
MOST DESTRUCTIVE. LAST YEAR
THERE WERE NEARLY NINE THOUSAND
WILDFIRES ACROSS THE STATE THAT
BURNED OVER TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION ACRES FOR COMPARISON-
THAT'S LARGER THAN THE AREA OF
THE STATE OF RHODE ISLAND AND
DELAWARE PUT TOGETHER. THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WILDFIRE YEAR.
IS WELL UNDER WAY WE ARE
FORTUNATE THAT WE SAW RECORD
RAINFALL LAST YEAR AT THE END OF
THE YEAR. BUT OUR LUCK SEEMS TO
HAVE RUN OUT IS JANUARY FEBRUARY
HAVE DRIED OUT. ALREADY THIS
YEAR OUR FIREFIGHTERS HAVE
RESPONDED. TO OVER SIX HUNDRED
WILDFIRES THAT HAVE ALREADY
BURNED NEARLY SIX THOUSAND
ACRES- THIS INCLUDES A NEARLY
SEVEN THOUSAND. NOT NEARLY SEVEN
HUNDRED ACRE WILDFIRE ALONG THE
COAST NEAR BIG SUR- THAT WAS
BACK IN JANUARY AND THEN- JUST
LAST MONTH THE FOUR THOUSAND
PLUS ACRE WILDFIRE JUST EAST OF
BISHOP. THE DESPITE OUR RECORD
SETTING FIRE SEASON SO CAL FIRE
HAS CONTINUED ITS FOCUS UPON
INCREASING THE PACE AND SCALE OF
FIRE PREVENTION ACTIVITIES AS A
KEY ELEMENT. IN OUR BATTLE
AGAINST THE DESTRUCTIVE AND
DEADLY WILDFIRE. A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF OUR WILDFIRE
STRATEGY CONTINUES TO STRESS THE
NEED TO ENSURE COMMUNITIES ARE
PREPARED FOR WILDFIRE BY
BUILDING AND RETROFITTING HOMES
WITH EMBER RESISTANT BUILDING
MATERIALS. VOLUNTARY HOMES HAVE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE WITH A MINIMUM
OF A HUNDRED FEET OF CLEARANCE
FROM DRIVE EDUCATION. NOW THANKS
TO A MULTI YEAR FUNDING
ALLOCATIONS ARE DESIGNATED AND
SENATOR ROD JUST BE NINE A ONE
FROM TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS WELL AS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING ALLOCATED BY
THE LEGISLATURE IN CAL FIRE'S
BUDGET. CALIFORNIA HAS CONTINUED
TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
IN ASSISTING COMMUNITIES MAKE
THESE MITIGATION EFFORTS. LAST
FALL WE AWARDED A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN
LOCAL WILDFIRE PREVENTION GRANTS
FOR FUEL REDUCTION WILDFIRE
PLANNING AND PUBLIC EDUCATION.
JUST LAST MONTH WE CLOSED AN
ADDITIONAL SOLICITATION PERIOD
FOR GRANTS FOR AN ADDITIONAL ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE PLAN TO AWARD AT
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY GROUPS LATER
THIS SPRING. A PER A SIMPLY BILL
THIRTY EIGHT AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOOD IN TWENTY
NINETEEN ALONG WITH OUR PARTNERS
AT CALLAWAY YES WE HAVE BEEN
BUSY DEVELOPING A NEW HOME
HARDENING RETROFIT FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. TO MAKE SURE
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS GET HELP IN
HARDENING THEIR HOMES AGAINST
THE EMBERS AND FLAMES OF
WILDFIRES. THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO EXCUSE ME
WILDFIRE FOREST RESILIENCE
PACKAGE ALSO AUGMENTED CAL
FIRE'S LOCAL UNIT FUNDING- WITH
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR FUEL
BREAKS AND FUEL REDUCTION IN
AROUND COMMUNITY. CALIFORNIA
ARGUABLY HAS THE MOST STRINGENT
BUILDING CODES IN THE WORLD
SPECIFICALLY FOR WILDLAND AREA.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT NEW
CONSTRUCTION IN CALIFORNIA HIGH
FIRE RISK AREAS REQUIRE BUILDING
MATERIALS THAT ARE MORE AMBER
RESISTANCE. NOW WE'RE CONSTANTLY
REEVALUATING THESE REQUIREMENTS
AND ADOPTING THE ATEST BUILDING
TECHNOLOGIES STANDARDS AND
MATERIALS. FROM THIS COLD WE
DEVELOPED A LIST OF LOW COST
RETROFITS TO PROVIDE RELATIVELY
CHEAP AND EASY UPGRADES THAT
RESIDENTS CAN MAKE ON THEIR OWN-
TO INCREASE THEIR HOMES CHANCE
OF SURVIVAL. THIS LIST IS
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC TODAY
OUR WEBSITE READY FOR WILDFIRE
.ORG. AS YOU KNOW CAL FIRE IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR NUMEROUS FIRE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS AS THE
STATE'S FIRE DEPARTMENT WE ARE
EXPERTS IN FIRE BEHAVIOR IN
CALIFORNIA'S LANDSCAPE. OVER THE
PAST YEARS WE HAVE CONTINUED TO
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE AND VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS TO BUILD THE SAFER
FROM WILDFIRES FRAMEWORK THE
MISTER PETERSON- MENTION. NOW
ALWAYS BEEN TO PROVIDE OUR
EXPERTISE AND IT IT AND HELP
INFORM CONSISTENT STATEWIDE
STANDARDS FOR HOME AND COMMUNITY
HARDING THAT WILL HELP REDUCE
WILDFIRE RISKS. REDUCING
WILDFIRE RISK IS A SHARED FOCUS
AMONG THE PARTNERS- AND THIS
UNIFIED WORK STRENGTHENS RISK
REDUCTION IN PREPAREDNESS IN
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY. THE
SAFER FROM WILDFIRES FRAMEWORK
IS IN LINE WITH OUR REQUIREMENTS
ARE BEST PRACTICES AS WELL AS
THE LATEST SCIENCE AND RESEARCH
. ALL THE AGENCIES ARE THAT WERE
INVOLVED IN THE DEVELOPMENT HAVE
TREMENDOUS IN HOUSE EXPERIENCE
IN VARIOUS ELEMENTS OF WILDFIRE
MITIGATON. NOW WE MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO PREVENT ALL CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES BUT HAVING A LIST OF
ACTIONS THAT IS ACHIEVABLE. AND
EFFECTIVE WILL HELP US SAVE
LIVES AND PROTECT HOMES AND
BUSINESSES. SENDING A UNIFIED
MESSAGE TO CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIANS IS CRITICAL IN
TRULY BECOMING SAFER. THE
FRAMEWORK WORKS WITH
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING WILDFIRE
STRATEGY INCLUDING STANDARDS FOR
NEW DEVELOPMENT AND DEFENSIBLE
SPACE. THE MEASURES LISTED IN
FAVOR OF WILDFIRES WILL BE
HELPFUL TO OUR FIREFIGHTERS BY
REDUCING RISK TO STRUCTURES
FREEING UP RESOURCES. AS WE
PREPARE FOR ANOTHER POTENTIALLY
DESTRUCTIVE FIRE SEASON AND
REALLY A FIRE YEAR IT'S CRITICAL
THAT THESE WILDFIRE MITIGATION
MEASURES ARE CONSIDERED IN NOT
ONLY INSURANCE AVAILABILITY BUT
ALSO IN INCENTIVES. TO ALL
PRECLUDE OUT THIS MORNING WITH A
REMINDER DON'T LET THE CALENDAR
FOR YOU THIS IS THE TIME OF YEAR
WHEN WE SHOULD ALL BE GETTING
OUR HOMES OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AND
OUR COMMUNITIES READY FOR
WILDFIRE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME THIS MORNING I
LOOK FOR TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU
MISTER BERLIN FIRST OF ALL DOES
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE WORK THAT
YOU DO AND PLEASE THANK YOUR
TEAM AND- IT WAS GREAT THAT WE
CAN REMIND CALIFORNIANS. THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'VE DONE AS
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
AS WELL AND- AND WE DEFINITELY
HAVE QUESTIONS FOR YOU A LITTLE
LATER ON TODAY SO THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
PRESENTER. WE HAVE AMY- I'M
SORRY NEXT WE HAVE- FROM CAL E.
S. RYAN BURRIS. WHO IS THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF RECOVERY AT
HELLO YES MR BURRIS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR JOINING US HERE
TODAY AND YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. GOOD MORNING JRUBY OWNED
BY STAR JONES AND MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON INSURANCE
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME
VIRTUALLY HERE TODAY. THIS IS-
IBEROSTAR DRUG THEIR RECOVERY
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. AS MANY OF
YOU MAY ALREADY BE AWARE-
EMERGENCIES ENVIRONMENT
DISASTERS WE ASK IN ADDITION TO
THE CONTINUED PRESENCE. OF ECHO
IN NINETEEN VIRUS AND ITS
VARIANTS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCED AN UNPRECEDENTED
NUMBER. OF WILDFIRES WITHIN JUST
THE LAST THREE YEARS. AND TWENTY
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ALONE WILDFIRES BURNED MILLIONS
OF ACRES. AND DAMAGED OVER.
THOUSANDS OF STRUCTURES THE
DESTRUCTION CAUSED BY THESE
FIRES AFFECTED. MANY ARE MORE
THAN FIFTY CALIFORNIA COUNTIES
AND CREATED AN INCREDIBLY
DANGEROUS LIVING APARTMENT FOR
MILLIONS OF RESIDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. AS CLIMATE CHANGES
INTENSIFY CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES
IN THE COMING YEARS IT'S
IMPERATIVE. THAT WE BEGIN
PROTECTING THE HOME OF THE
COMMUNITIES IN DISASTER.
IMPACTED AREAS. THE STATE HAS A
LONG TERM STRATEGY TO PROTECT
COMMUNITIES FROM WILDFIRES WHICH
FOCUSES ON REDUCING AND
ELIMINATING AND YOUR REST. AND
IMPACTS OF NATURAL AND HUMAN
DISASTERS. THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AS A MITIGATION PLAN USES THE
LATEST FIRE SCIENCE AND PROVIDE
STRATEGIES. TO GET THE REST OF
THE HIGHEST. NEEDS AREAS SUCH AS
LANDSCAPE LEVEL INTERVENTIONS
SUCH AS FOREST VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT ACTIVITIES COMMUNITY
LEVEL. DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE HARDENING AND
HOMEOWNER LEVEL INTERVENTIONS
SUCH AS HOME HARD AND PROPERTY.
LEVEL DEFENSE WITH EIGHT. WE'RE
ALSO WORKING WITH YOU TO SAY I
MEAN WITH I CAN SO THAT THEY
CAN. IN ORNATE THEIR OWN LOCAL
RISK ASSESS AND PLANS FROM ALL
OUR MITIGATION STRATEGIES. THE
LOCAL PLANS ARE CALLED LOCAL
HAZARD MITIGATION PLANS AND WE
HAVE STAFF ON SITE. TO WORK WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEADERS TO
ENSURE THAT THEY DEVELOP AND
UPDATE PLANS SO THAT IT ALSO
MEETS THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
ELIGIBILITY TO APPLY FOR FEMA
HAZARD MITIGATION ASSISTANCE.
GRANT PROGRAMS. HELLO YES IS A
FEW FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WORK TO REDUCE THE EFFECTS OF
FUTURE NATURAL DISASTERS
ALTHOUGH MOST OF OUR PROJECTS
ARE FUNDED. TEAM IS HAS A
MITIGATION GRANT PROGRAM. WE ARE
PLEASED TO ANNOUNCE A NEW ONE
TIME STATE FUNDED INITIATIVE OUT
THERE CALIFORNIA INCOME
HARDENING WHICH HELPS SOCIAL
BONOBO IN. HIGH HAZARD RISK
COMMUNITIES JUMPSTART THEIR
PROGRESS TOWARD GREATER
RESILIENCE. THE FOLLOWING
FEDERAL. HAZARD MITIGATION
FUNDING CAN BE ALLOCATED
STRATEGICALLY TO MEET MEDICATION
GOALS. HAS MITIGATION GRANT
PROGRAM IS A POSTMASTER GRAND
OPPORTUNITY THAT ON 75% OF
MEDICATION ASIAN PROJECTS. LOCAL
HAS MITIGATION CREATION AND
UPDATES. AND PROJECT PLAN AND-
THE ONLY REASON INFRASTRUCTURE
COMMUNITIES IS AN ANNUAL
NATIONAL COMPETITIVE PROGRAM.
THROUGH FEMA ONE BILLION SO
VALUABLE IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THAT FOUND 75% OF LARGE SCALE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
MITIGATION. EMPHASIZE AN
APPLICATION OF NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS FOR HAZARD RISK
REDUCTION IN PROTECTION OF
ARTICLE NEEDS. REPAIR
CALIFORNIA. EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
IN STATE FUNDS TO COVER THAT 25%
MATS AND FIFTY MILLION STATE
FUNDS FOR CAPACITY BUILDING
ACTIVITIES. THESE OPPORTUNITIES
WALKER COMMUNITIES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADVANCE THEIR
ABILITY TO UNDERTAKE RESILIENCY
PROJECTS AND FINANCE YOU
PARTICIPATE AS A MITIGATION
GRANT PROGRAMS FOR THE HIGHEST
RESCUE MOST SOCIALLY BARBEL.
IMMUNITIES AS A MITIGATION GRANT
PROGRAMS THE BRIDGE PROGRAM AND
PREPARE CALIFORNIA MATCH FUNDING
CAN SPECIFICALLY PROTECT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PEOPLE
MAINTAIN. VEGETATION GREAT
DEFENSE WAS BASED NEAR TOWNS
INSTRUCTS. CALIFORNIA ABOUT FIVE
MINUTE. CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE
MITIGATION. PROGRAM WILL FIND
HOPE COMMUNITY. RAY HOME AND WAS
SECTOR BUT SOCIAL. BARBER
HOMEOWNERS CURRENTLY WORKING
INTO DEMONSTRATION COMMUNITIES
BEFORE EXPANDING ACROSS THE
STATE. B. FLOOD MANAGEMENT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IS THE ANNUAL
NATIONAL COMPETITIVE PROGRAM
THROUGH FEMA THAT PROTECTS. NFIP
INSURED PROPERTIES FROM FLOODING
THIS CAN BE USED TO REDUCE POST
FIRE DEBRIS FLOW RESTS IN
REPETITIVE LOSS PROPERTIES AND
HOME HARDIN. YES AND CAL FIRE IS
WORKING WITH THE READ THAT
WITHOUT THREE DEMONSTRATES
COMMUNITIES TO HARDEN HOMES AND
THEIR HIGHEST REST MOST SOCIALLY
BOND WHEN NEIGHBORHOODS WE'RE
LEVERAGING 75% OF THE COST. FROM
THE FEMA HAZARD MITIGATION GRANT
PROGRAM THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AT THIS
YEAR AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS THAT
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. I N. EVERYONE'S
BEEN KEEPING A VERY CONCISE I
APPRECIATE ALL THE PRESENTERS.
WE WILL GO TO IN OUR FINAL
PRESENTER AND THEN WE'LL HAVE
QUESTIONS AFTER- WELCOME AMY.
BACH EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
UNITED POLICY HOLDERS ON A
SIMILAR INITIATIVE. THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON TO BENEFIT
HOMEOWNERS MISBACH THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US HERE TODAY AND YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
AS THE CHAIR RUBIO VICE CHAIR
JONES AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I'M IN THE BOX AND IT
IS MY ABSOLUTE PLEASURE TO BE
HERE PRESENTING. A CHIEF- THIS
MORNING AND WITH SUCH A- AN
IMPORTANT GROUP OF STAKEHOLDERS.
AND- FIGHTING INFORMATION ON A
TOPIC THAT I KNOW YOUR MEMBERS
HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE WITH
PERSONALLY- BECAUSE OF
CONSTITUENT ISSUES AND YOU'RE
ALL- PRETTY WELL STEEPED IN IN
THE TOPICS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TODAY. SO WHY IS MY LITTLE
ORGANIZATION HERE- IT'S BECAUSE
WE HAVE HAD A- SUBSTANTIAL ROLE
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS IN
HELPING- WITH. KEEPING THE
MOMENTUM GOING THAT YOU'RE
HEARING ABOUT TODAY I'M WE ARE
FIVE ONE C. THREE WE HAVE BEEN
AROUND SINCE RIGHT AROUND THE
TIME OF THE OAKLAND BERKELEY
FIRE. SO AND- IN THIS VERY
FOCUSED ON WILDFIRE PREPAREDNESS
AND RECOVERY- THE RAP PROGRAM
THAT YOU HEARD MIKE PETERSON
REFERENCE WHICH STANDS FOR
WILDFIRE RISK REDUCTION IN ASSET
PROTECTION INITIATIVE. IS UNDER
OUR- SORT OF CROSSES ALL OF OUR
PROGRAMS DISASTER PREPAREDNESS
RECOVERY AND ADVOCACY- IT IS AN
OUTGROWTH- HELLO. WE GOT WE WERE
CONTACTED BY ELECTED OFFICIALS
IN A NUMBER OF AREAS AROUND
CALIFORNIA. SHORTLY AFTER THE
TREE MORTALITY CRISIS WAS
EMERGING. AND OPTIONS WERE
SHRINKING FOR HOMEOWNERS AND
BECAUSE I'M INVOLVED AND AT THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS AS AN-
OFFICIAL CONSUMER REP THERE. I
HAD BEEN WORKING STARTING IN
ABOUT TWENTY FIFTEEN WITH SOME
OF THE HURRICANE PRONE STATES-
ON THEIR INSURANCE DEPARTMENTS
AND THE PROGRAMS THAT THEY WERE
OFFERING. TO FACILITATE RISK
REDUCTION AND INSURANCE REWARDS
I HAD A LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND
THERE SO WHEN WE STARTED- TRYING
TO HELP PEOPLE IN THE HERE AND
NOW IN CALIFORNIA WHO WERE
LOSING INSURANCE AND- HAVING
AND- THEY ARE THEY'RE- NOT QUITE
KNOWING WHAT TO DO ABOUT IT. WE
LAUNCHED THIS INITIATIVE- AND WE
HAVE BANNED NOW I THINK WE'RE ON
OUR NINETEENTH MEETING OF
CONVENING STAKEHOLDERS AND WE'VE
HAD- REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
AGENCIES THAT YOU'VE JUST HEARD
FROM- WE HAVE HAD I. D. H. S.
SOME OF THE VENDORS THAT ARE-
DOING RISK REDUCTION HAVE
PRESENTED TO US S. D. INSIDE
CHINA. AND SO- BUT MOSTLY WHAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING IS JUST TRYING
TO GATHER INFORMATION. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THESE FOUR GOALS AND
REDUCING RISK RESTORING HOME
INSURANCE AVAILABILITY AND
AFFORDABILITY. AND AND
ESTABLISHING STANDARDS FOR
EXISTING HOMES- SO THAT THERE
WOULD BE A BENCHMARK. TO MEASURE
AND INSURER IN GAUGE AND THE
FINANCE REWARDS WE KNOW THAT ARE
SO CALLED. TO MAKE IT BOTH- AND
TRACTIVE TO HOMEOWNERS TO INVEST
TIME AND MONEY IN RISK
REDUCTION- BUT AT BUT ALSO TO
MAKE IT FINANCIALLY WORTHWHILE
FOR. BOTH IN TERMS OF HAVING
THEIR HOMES- AND BE EASIER TO
INSURE BUT ALSO HAVING THEIR
HOMES- MAINTAIN THEIR VALUE TO
REAL ESTATE VALUE- AS A AS A- A
SAFER FROM WILDFIRE HOLDER WHICH
REDUCE HOME. SO I FOCUS NOW A WE
MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS WITH HELP
FROM A LOT OF THE FOLKS THAT ARE
HERE- IS VERY MUCH ON NOW THE
NUTS AND BOLTS SO- BUILDING
FINANCIAL IMPACT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE OPTIONS. AND I JUST
REALLY CONTINUING TO BUILD ON
THE AMAZING WORK THAT FIRE SAFE
GROUPS FIREWISE GROUPS. ARE
DOING IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
THAT CAL FIRE AND LOCAL FIRE
AGENCIES HAVE BEEN DOING FOR
MANY MANY YEARS AT A LOCAL LEVEL
TO HELP THEIR HOMEOWNERS KNOW
WHAT TO DO. AND HOW TO DO IT
YEAH AND THEN B. A LOT OF LOCAL
FIRE AGENCIES HAD BEEN A GO
BETWEEN BETWEEN HOMEOWNERS AND
THEIR INSURERS TO GIVE THE
INSURERS SOME. COMFORT THAT THIS
IS A BETTER THAN AVERAGE RISK
EVEN THOUGH IT IS IN THE MOVIE
SO- OUR WORKING GROUP PUT OUT-
THIS IS A SERIES OF RECOMMENDED
STEPS- LAST FALL. THEN I DHS PUT
THEIRS OUT THE INTERAGENCY
PARTNERSHIP BUT THERE IS OUT IN
THIS CHART HELPS YOU SEE THERE'S
TREMENDOUS OVERLAP YOU KNOW THIS
TIME OF THIS MORNING'S HEARING I
HOPE WILL BE A FEEL GOOD FOR
EVERYONE THERE'S A LOT OF BAD
NEWS OUT THERE BUT ON THIS
TOPIC- THERE'S A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT. OF OF CLEAN BY I'D SAY I
THINK THE INSURERS ARE COMING-
UNDER OUR TEN I THINK YOU KNOW
THAT WE ARE ALL KIND F SEEM TO
BE MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
TOGETHER. SO WE DO HAVE- STILL
OF COURSE LOTS OF WORK TO BE HE
DIED BUT THERE'S A LOT. OF
BETWEEN WHAT THIS. ARE SAYING.
IS EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING
WILDFIRE RISK WHICH AT THE END
OF THE DAY. IS REALLY THE KEY
HERE IS TO GIVE YOU KNOW GIVE
INSURERS THAT CONFIDENCE- THAT-
YOU KNOW TO INVEST IN THESE
COMMUNITIES AND THEN TO. TO GIVE
PEOPLE REWARDS SO. I HAVE A LOT
OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING THROUGH
THE RAP PROGRAM OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS. HAS BEEN- GATHERING
INFORMATION SO THIS IS JUST FROM
ONE OF OUR THIS THIS AND THIS
WEEK'S MEETING- WE HEARD FROM
THREE OF THE FIRE SAFE COUNCILS-
THAT ARE. THAT HAVE PROGRAMS
GOING IN THEIR COMMUNITIES SO
WE'RE GATHERING INFORMATION FROM
THEM ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE DOING ON
THE GROUND AND THERE'S A LOT OF.
REALLY GOOD WORK GOING ON IN
COMMUNITIES CREATIVE WORK- AND
COLLABORATIVE WORK. SO JUST A
FEW OTHER THINGS- MY
ORGANIZATION WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE- WE'VE WE DO A LOT OF
CONSUMER EDUCATION- TO HELP
PEOPLE FIND INSURANCE OPTIONS.
WE ARE CONTINUING TO- TAKE THE
PULSE OF THE PROPERTY INSURANCE
MARKET PLACE TO SURVEY- THAT WE
HAVE GOING ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE IS HELPING US WITH
THAT. AS OUR PARTNERS AT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND- ALL THE FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS AS WELL SO WE'RE
GETTING INFORMATION ON WHAT
PEOPLE ARE DOING ON THEIR OWN.
AND WHAT KIND OF STANDARDS THEY
ARE USING IN THEIR LOCAL
PROGRAMS- AND THEN WE ARE DOING
SOME WORK AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
AND JUST TO SEE YOU KNOW KEEP
TABS ON WHAT OTHER STATES HAVE
DONE. YOU KNOW WHEN THERE'S JUST
THREE MAIN APPROACHES THAT OTHER
STATES HAVE TAKEN THERE ARE
LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED RISK
REDUCTION DISCOUNTS- THERE ARE
LEGISLATIVE. LEE MANDATED
NOTICES AND OFFERS NOT
NECESSARILY A PRESCRIBED-
DISCOUNT BUT AT- A REQUIREMENT
THAT INSURERS DO SOME KIND OF.
RECOGNITION AND THEN OF COURSE
IS THERE SOME AMAZING. VOLUNTARY
PROGRAMS- THE FIREWISE USA FIRE
SAFE COUNCILS- IT'S SUCH A- WE
HAVE A LITTLE PILOT GOING IN SAN
DIEGO WITH THE COUNTY AND- A LOT
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW IS YOU
KNOW JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT-
WHERE TO GET HOW TO GET THE
MONEY INTO THE HANDS. OF
COMMUNITIES AND INDIVIDUALS- IT
ALSO AND HOW TO SOLVE THOSE KIND
OF. THE CHALLENGES- WE KNOW THAT
IT'S NOT ENOUGH FOR ONE
HOMEOWNERS DO SOMETHING IT
REALLY HAS TO BE- POSSIBLE. SO
IT HAS TO BE INDIVIDUAL AND
COMMUNITY LEVEL IN ORDER TO GIVE
INSURERS THE CONFIDENCE THAT
THEY NEED- SO NEXT STEPS WE NEED
TO FINALIZE THE REGULATIONS OF
THE DEPARTMENT IS PUT UT
THEY'VE BEEN DOING REALLY GOOD
WORK. AND BEING VERY THOUGHTFUL
THEY'VE GONE A COUPLE ROUNDS OF
- I HAVE MEETINGS BEFORE THEY
ISSUED THEIR THEIR DEPENDING RAG
SO THEY REALLY HAVE TRIED VERY
HARD TO LISTEN TO ALL THE
PARTIES- AND WE ARE SUPPORTING
THOSE REGULATIONS STRONGLY. AS
ARE A LOT OF OUR FIRE SAFE
COUNCIL FOLKS AND PARTNERS. WE
HAVE NOT SOME BOLTS TO FIGURE
OUT AS TO WHO DOES THE
INSPECTIONS WHOSE CERTIFIES THAT
A HOME IS. SAFER FROM WILDFIRES-
AND THEN OF COURSE- INSURERS I
HAVE TO ADAPT TO- THIS THIS. NEW
SITUATION. AND YOU'VE HEARD
THERE'S A LOT MORE MONEY COMING
IN NOW FROM THE FANS- AND FROM
THE STATE. SO THOSE ARE ALL I'M
I THAT THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE COUP BY YA RIGHT SO
THAT THAT WE'RE MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION- AND JUST TO
CLOSE BY SAYING THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE WORK THAT. THIS HOUSE IS
DUE TO THE LEGISLATURE IS DOING-
I WOULD REALLY ENCOURAGE ANY OF
YOU. WHO DO YOU DO CONSTITUENT
NEWSLETTERS IF YOU WANT TO HELP-
US KEEP. KEEP TAKING A PULSE- OF
THE OF THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA IRVINE HOW. HOW
THEY'RE DOING WITH THEIR HOME
INSURANCE AND IT WOULD BE MOST
APPRECIATED SO THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR TIME- AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS. THAT YOUR MEMBERS MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH A FOR
THAT. AND IT THANK YOU FOR THE
THIRTY YEARS THAT YOUR
ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN WORKING ON
SOME OF THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES-
YOU'RE DOWN IN THE TRENCHES SO
TO SPEAK SO WE APPRECIATE THAT.
YOU KNOW IT SEEMS LIKE EVERYONE
IS IN THE SPIRIT OF
COLLABORATION AND COOPERATION I
THINK WE'RE ALL GETTING ON THE
SAME PAGE WHICH IS FANTASTIC- SO
I JUST WANT TO SHARE WITH OUR-
MEMBERS THIS CONCLUDES OUR FIRST
PANEL SO I WANT TO TURN IT OVER
TO OUR MEMBERS TO ASK QUESTIONS.
PLEASE RAISE YOUR MICROPHONES IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK. MR DOT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH JRUBY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY
AT THIS HEARING THANK YOU FOR-
SCHEDULING IT. I ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO THANK ALL THE SPEAKERS I
THINK THEY WERE ALL. OF YOUR
VERY GOOD- IN PARTICULAR AT THE
END AMY BACH I THINK KIND OF
BROUGHT IT ALL. YOUR DOWN TO
WHERE WE ARE AND I THINK YOU ARE
TAKE YOU IT IT VERY WELL IN
TERMS OF- WERE ALL KIND OF
GETTING ON THE SAME PAGE AND-
WORKING TOGETHER. I THINK THE-
I'D LIKE TO PEEL BACK THE ONION
JUST A LITTLE BIT HERE AND IT
ASK QUESTION AND MAYBE A COUPLE
DIFFERENT SPEAKERS MIGHT.
ADDRESS IT. IT SEEMS AS THOUGH
THIS IS NOT RIPPING ON INSURANCE
COMPANIES LOOK AT WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THESE HAVE BEEN. AND
I DO SEE MISTER- FRAZIER'S
LETTER FROM PATH. IN A SPELL OUT
VERY CLEARLY ABOUT YOU KNOW
JUST. YOU KNOW HOW MANY HOMES
HAVE BEEN LOST WHAT KIND OF
DAMAGE IS BEEN DONE. THROUGHOUT
THESE AREAS AND WE KNOW THAT-
YOU KNOW THE BACKBONE OF THE
INSURANCE BUSINESS AND HOW IT
WORKS- I'VE BEEN NOTICING IN MY
AREAS THAT- ALL. IT SEEMS THAT A
LOT OF THE CANCELLATION NOTICES
AND EVERYTHING AND BECOMING BY-
ZIP CODES. IN WHAT'S HAPPENED IN
A LOT OF THESE VIRUSES ARE SO
SMALL THEY'RE ALL IN THE SAME
ZIP CODE PRACTICALLY. ELISE
COUNTY BY COUNTY SO NO MY COUNTY
NAPA COUNTY SOLANO COUNTY YOLO
COUNTY THEY EACH ONLY HAD MAYBE
ONE OR TWO ZIP CODES AND THEY'RE
ALL THE SAME. IT DOES HI PRONE
FIRE AREAS. SO MY QUESTION
BECOMES OKAY. THESE FIRE WISE
COUNSELS AS MISS BAKIT- POINTED
OUT ARE REALLY DOING A GREAT JOB
WE'RE GETTING MONEY OUT IN THESE
AREAS. WHO IS IT ALTERNATELY
THAT CERTIFIES LET'S JUST SAY
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU CAN'T
DO IT BY ZIP CODE. YEAH FOR
THESE DIFFERENT WATERSHEDS WOULD
BE BY CENSUS TRACT TO DETERMINE
OKAY IF A FIRE WISE COUNSEL
THAT- HANDLES A WHOLE WATERSHED.
DAVE'S CERTIFY THAT THEY ARE
FIRE SAFE IN THE WHOLE YOU KNOW
LARGER NEIGHBORHOOD THE CONTEXT
OF THE NEIGHBORHOODS WHO
CERTIFIES THAT IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT CAL FIRE DOES- IT MAY GIVE
US THE INFORMATION TO CBI IN CDI
TO THE INSURANCE COMPANIES I
JUST THINK THAT. WE NEED TO HAVE
SOME SORT OF CLEARING HOUSE BOB
WHAT'S GETTING DONE SO THIS
INFORMATION OR MAYBE THE POT ALL
TO BELIEVE WHEN SOMEBODY'S-
AREAS CERTIFIED MAYBE THE
HOMEOWNER HAS A CERTIFICATION
AND THEY- YOU KNOW GIVE IT TO
THE INSURANCE COMPANY STILL NOT
CLEAR ON THAT WE'RE PROBABLY NOT
THERE YET BUT- I JUST KIND OF
WANT TO. PRESUPPOSE SOME
POSSIBILITIES TO MAKE IT BETTER
FOR EVERYBODY THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR DODD
WOULD ANYONE LIKE TO COMMENT. OR
RESPOND TO MR DOT PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND. I DON'T SEE ANY
HANDS- ANY OTHER PANELISTS
WISHING TO MAKE A COMMENT. I'M
HAPPY TO MAKE A BRIEF COMMENT
THANK YOU GO AHEAD UP. AMY BACH
AND YOU KNOW SENATOR JOHN SPOT
ON- INSURERS HAVE BEEN.
GENERALLY SAYING THEY DON'T WANT
TO BE THE ONES. TO GO OUT AND DO
REPEATED INSPECTIONS I KNOW THAT
I. D. H. S. HAS A CONCEPT I
UNDERSTAND THEY WERE HERE-
RECENTLY MEETING- WITH SOME OF
OUR FIRE- FIREFIGHTING
PROFESSIONALS BUT- I DON'T KNOW
HOW DETAILED I DON'T KNOW IF SHE
FOR LAND IS ABLE TO SHARE. IT
HOW GRANULAR THEIR PLAN IS- FOR
THEM HAVING THE INSPECTION
FORCE- BUT I KNOW THEY THEY OF
THE ONLY PEOPLE I'VE HEARD OF
THAT HAVE EXPRESSED AN INTEREST
IN BEING THE ONES TO DO THE- THE
INSPECTIONS BUT I'M NOT SURE IF
THROUGH WHETHER THEY WANT TO USE
LIKE THE SAME PEOPLE THAT GO OUT
AND DO- PROPERTY APPRAISALS FOR-
MORTGAGES I DON'T KNOW. IF I
COULD- TAG ON AGAIN NOT GETTING
BLANKED WITHOUT CAL FIRE. CENTER
DOT TV TO YOUR EARLIER QUESTION
OBVIOUSLY WE PROVIDE PERSONAL
LEVEL INSPECTIONS- AS PART OF
OUR DEFENSE WILL SPACE PROGRAM
WE PROVIDE. A HOME HARDING-
TIPS- IS A PART OF THAT BUT HOW
DO YOU DEFINE THE COMMUNITY- YOU
KNOW YOU MENTIONED ZIP CODE AT
FIRST- CENSUS TRACT- DEFINING
THE COMMUNITY IS THE COMPLEX ON.
THE ITEM THAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON
AS AMY MENTIONED- I. B. H. S.
WHICH IS THE NONPROFIT AND
RESEARCH ARM OF THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY WAS OUT HERE- JUST LAST
WEEK WE ARE MEETING WITH THEM
AND- THEY ARE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH US AND WITH. A
NUMBER OF STAKEHOLDERS. IN THE
FIRE MITIGATION WORLD TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THAT IN HALF AND TO FIND
THAT I POINT OUT A COUPLE ITEMS
THOUGH. AS WAS MENTIONED BY
NUMBER THE SPEAKERS N. F. PA'S
FIREWISE COMMUNITIES IS MORE OR
LESS THAT SELF CERTIFICATION AND
RECOGNITION PROGRAM- THAT THAT
THAT DEFINES ALLOWS THE
HOMEOWNERS AS A GRASSROOTS
EFFORT TO KIND OF DEFINE WHAT
THEIR COMMUNITY LOOKS LIKE- THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY- IS ALSO
WORKING. TO DEVELOP A NEW- FIRE
RISK REDUCTION COMMUNITY-
CERTIFICATION THAT'S STILL UNDER
THE REGULATORY- PROCESS RIGHT
NOW SO THEY'RE WORKING TO HIT
WERE STAKEHOLDERS TO DEFINE
THAT. BUT THAT'S GOING TO BE AND
I THINK ANOTHER AVENUE OF AGAIN
FOR LACK OF BETTER WORD
CERTIFICATION THAT THIS
COMMUNITY IS MEETING THE
COMMUNITY WIDE LEVEL OF
PERSPECTIVE WE'VE BEEN VERY
FOCUSED. FOR YEARS ON INSURING
THAT HOMEOWNERS ARE DOING THEIR
PART BUT WHAT WE'RE FINDING IN
IN MANY OF THESE WILDFIRES IS
THAT- JUST BECAUSE YOU'VE DONE
YOUR DEFENSIBLE SPACE. DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEAN THAT YOUR HOME
IS GOING TO SURVIVE A WILDFIRE
IF YOUR NEIGHBOR ESPECIALLY IF
YOU LIVE IN A DENSE AREA OF YOUR
NEIGHBORS CLOSE BY. IF YOUR
NEIGHBOR HAS NOT DONE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE IN YOUR NEIGHBOR'S HOME IS
NOT BUILT OR RETROFITTED IN
THEIR HOME IGNITES ON FIRE IT'S
VERY LIKELY THAT IT'S GOING TO
SPREAD TO YOUR HOME SO. TAKING
TAKING A STEP BACK AWAY FROM THE
PARCEL. AND LOOKING AT THE
COMMUNITY IT'S SO. IS THE FOCUS
NOW MR PETER DID I MENTION AS
WELL THAT IS A COMPLETE. OF THE
SAFER FOR WILDFIRES- THE
WILDFIRE- PROGRAM A LET HIM
OBVIOUSLY TALK MORE ABOUT THAT
BUT- I GUESS I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT. YES THE QUESTION SOULS WHO
CERTIFIES IT BUT I WOULDN'T I
WOULD NOTE THAT THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION-
FIREWISE COMMUNITIES AND I. B.
H. S. I THINK ALL ARE LOOKING
AT. SOME LEVEL OF DESIGNATION
FOR COMMUNITIES THAT ARE MEETING
ALL OF THESE MITIGATION
STRATEGIES. THANK YOU FOR THAT
MR DOT YOU HAVE A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION YES I APPRECIATE BOTH
OF THOSE THE ANSWERS- I WOULD
STRESS THAT- GETTING SOME SORT
OF RESOLUTION TO THAT. AND HOW
THAT'S DONE FOR CERTIFICATION IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR
DODD FOR YOUR QUESTION I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO SENATOR ARCHULETA YOU
HAVE A QUESTION YES THANK YOU
MANAGER KEPT QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS- I JUST LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT. I THINK JENNER DOG
BROUGHT UP A GOOD POINT- WHEN
YOU HAVE HOMEOWNERS SHOULD CAN-
ACTUALLY FOLLOW THE RULES BE THE
GOOD GUYS. AND MAYBE THIRTY
FORTY FIFTY FEET- CLEAR AROUND
THEIR PROPERTY CLEAR IN AND BO.
BE AWARE OF. IT'S A HUNDRED
YOU'RE LUCKY TO GET A HUNDRED.
SO I'M SAYING LUCKY TO GET A
HUNDRED BUT IF THERE IS SOMEONE
WHO ACTUALLY GETS TO THAT LEVEL
TWO HUNDRED FEET- WHICH IS QUITE
DIFFICULT AND THERE'S NO DOUBT
BUT IF THEY DO- CAN THEY TAKE
PHOTOS AND SEND IT TO THEIR
INSURANCE COMPANY WITH THEIR
INSURANCE COMPANIES AND BE ABLE
TO REDUCE THEIR- THEIR ANNUAL
FEES BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
THE GOOD GUYS DOING SOMETHING TO
PREVENT FIRES. AND ALSO SHOW
THAT THEY'VE GOT- THE FIRE
DETECTION EQUIPMENT AND OTHER-
EXTINGUISHERS IN THE HOUSE SOME
WAY TO DO PARTICIPATE SO THEY
CAN RECEIVE- A LESSER RATE AND
THEY CAN DO THAT BY PHOTOS I
DON'T EXPECT THAT THE INSURANCE
AGENT TO GO OUT TO EACH AND
EVERY HOUSE. BUT MAYBE THEY
COULD DO IT THAT WAY THAT'S ONE
IF THAT WOULD BE ACCEPTABLE THE
OTHER THING IS I'D LIKE TO-
COMPLIMENT ALL THE FIREFIGHTERS
THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA CAL
FIRE'S BEEN PARTICULARLY THERE
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY THE- LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT
IN CONJUNCTION WITH SOME OF THE
OTHER FIRE DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE
AROUND- DOWN THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT- WORKING WITH WAIT
HERE- THERE WAS A HUGE FIRE TO
HOMES. WERE WERE- DAMAGE IT WAS
BECAUSE OF OUR SIN IT WASN'T
BECAUSE OF- THE BRUSH AND THE
TREES AND SO ON IT WAS RSON BUT
WHAT I HAVE TO COMPLIMENT ALL
THE FIREFIGHTERS WITH IS THE
FACT THAT IT SEEMS LIKE EVERYONE
PARTICIPATED AND AIR DROPS AND-
EQUIPMENT IT WAS AMAZING WHAT
THEY WERE ABLE TO DO IN A SHORT
TIME DISTINGUISH THAT FIRE. AND
PREVENT FURTHER DAMAGE TO MORE
HOMES ONLY TWO WERE DAMAGED SHOW
UP IT IS SO IMPORTANT WE DON'T
FORGET OUR COMMUNITY
FIREFIGHTERS WORKING IN THE
INNER CITY AND WORKING- WITH US
AND- MADAM CHAIR I BELIEVE YOUR
DISTRICT AT SOUTH EL MONTE HAD A
HUGE FIRE THERE ON ROSEMEAD
BOULEVARD THAT COULD ASSIST AT.
TO THE DUTCH AREA IN THE FIRE
FIRE DEPARTMENTS- QUICKLY
CONVERGE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT AND EXTINGUISH THAT. SO
COMPLIMENTS ON THAT BUT GOING
BACK TO- THE HOMEOWNERS I THINK
THAT THEY NEED HELP AS MUCH AS
WE CAN. AND THEN MY LAST
QUESTION. IT WHEN WE HAD ALL
THESE FIRES JUST MOST RECENTLY
WITH FEMA INVOLVED DO WE GET THE
RESULTS FROM FEMA WE WERE ASKING
FOR. IF ANYONE CAN ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS I'D APPRECIATE THANK
YOU MR TAYLOR FOR YOUR QUESTION
ANYONE WANT TO TAKE THE LAST
QUESTION IS ABOUT FEMA. PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND. MR BURRIS YOU
MAY PROCEED. THANKS I THANK
SENATOR SO IN REGARDS TO FEMA-
WE HAVE A B. THRESHOLD TO GET
ASSISTANCE- IN THIS STATE- IS
CURRENTLY SIXTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS- WE NEED TO HAVE AN
ESTIMATED DAMAGES TO BART
RECEIVE THAT- TO RECEIVE PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE UP FULLY AND
INDIVIDUAL SUSPENSE BUT WE ALSO
HAVE THE- FIRE GRANT AS WELL THE
DEATH MAG AND- WE DID RECEIVE
QUITE A FEW F. BAGS. LYCEUM
HAPPY TO PROVIDE A LAST BIT OF
FEMA HAS BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE
AND PROVIDE AN ETHNIC SUPPORT
WHICH DOES HELP US. RECOUP A LOT
OF THE MONEY THAT ROUTE WE ARE
SPEND PARTICULARLY EARLY ON AND
FIGHT THE FIRES- AND OF COURSE
IF THEY- IF WE EXTEMPORANEOUS
DISTANCE THERE'D BE NOAS FAR
AS- TOOLS AND OUR PEOPLE OF
EIGHTY ODD TO- ARRIVED AS WELL
WHEN WE DID GET. TO FULL
DECLARATIONS LAST YEAR FOR THE
AUGUST AND SEPTEMBER FIRES AND
EMAIL IS STILL CURRENTLY IN OUR
BUILDING HERE- YES WORKING EVERY
DAY TRYING TO HELP OUT THE.
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA OKAY
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION. THANK YOU
FOR THAT- THANK YOU MR. ONE OF
THE FOLLOW UP AND ON THAT
POSSIBILITY OF THE REDUCTION OF
THE- ANNUAL FEES FOR THOSE WHO
ADHERE. TO THE RULES OF KEEPING
THEIR PROPERTY FREE AND CLEAR
FROM DEBRIS. WELL THANK YOU FOR
THAT SO I'LL JUST FOLLOW UP ON
THAT I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PANELISTS I JUST HAVE ONE QUICK
QUESTION AND THAT'S FOR C. D. I.
N. N. AND I WANTED TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR AGAIN THE SPIRIT OF
COLLABORATION I KNOW THAT NOW-
YOU KNOW EVERYONE'S TALKING TO
ONE ANOTHER AND TRYING TO COME
UP WITH SOLUTIONS AND BUILD ON
WHAT. EACH ARM DEPARTMENT OR
AGENCY IS JOINED BY TOM I WANT
TO GO BACK TO C. D. I. MIKE
PETERSON AND- AMY. ARE BOTH OF
YOU TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE OUT
REACH YOU'VE BEEN DOING SO FIRST
OF ALL I THINK INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER WE GOT A LOT OF
BASED ON THE PRESENTATION HE'S
BEEN TO THIRTY SIX COUNTIES. AND
HAS HELPED FORTY FIVE VIRTUAL
MEETINGS BUT I JUST WANT YOU O
SHARE WHAT ARE THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES IN GETTING PEOPLE
ENGAGED- MISTRUST I JUST ASKED
THE QUESTION. HOW DO WE GET
THOSE INDIVIDUAL FOLKS TOM NOT
ONLY ENGAGE BUT ALSO TO LEARN
ABOUT THESE ISSUES WHAT IS YOUR
BIGGEST CHALLENGE AND HOW CAN WE
HELP. PUT THE INFORMATION OUT
THERE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT FOR THE QUESTIONS YOUR
REVIEW I THINK THAT. YOU KNOW
THIS FAVOR FROM WELFARE.
FRAMEWORK I GIVE THIS A
CONSISTENT APPROACH THAT.
MULTIPLE AGENCIES IT ALL WORKS
TO CREATE AND SO THAT'S A REALLY
EXCELLENT COMMUNICATION TOOL. TO
TALK WITH COMMUNITIES ABOUT AS
THEY'RE TRYING TO PREPARE. FOR A
FUTURE WILDFIRES AND SO I THINK.
YOU KNOW WE BY WORKING ON THIS
PROJECT. I THINK WE'VE CLARIFIED
A LOT OF SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WERE OUT THERE IN TERMS OF.
YOU KNOW OF THE MANY THINGS YOU
COULD DO TO REDUCE WILDFIRE RISK
WHERE SHOULD YOU CONCENTRATE
YOUR EFFORTS AND NOW THAT WE
HAVE A CONSISTENT APPROACH. YOU
WERE REALLY GOING TO BE TRYING
TO. THROUGH OUR REGION ENGAGING
WITH COMMUNITIES- ISSUE SURE
THAT APPROACH AND HELP CONNECT
PEOPLE WITH INFORMATION AND SO I
THINK THAT THAT. SOME OF THE
BIGGEST HELP IS THROUGH THE
COMMUNICATION. OF THIS
FRAMEWORK- ESPECIALLY HI. PRIOR
TO WHEN- FIVE FIRES. ARE GOING
TO ACCELERATE IN THE FUTURE I
DON'T WANT. YEAH I WOULD YOU
PROVIDE SO THAT WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE IN FIRE SEASON RIGHT NOW
BUT- BUT THE SOONER WE CAN
COMMUNICATE THE SOONER WE CAN
MITIGATE- THE MORE IN ADVANCE.
OF A FUTURE FIRES WILL BE. THANK
YOU. WELL ONCE AGAIN THANK TO
ALL THE PANELISTS AND TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR GREAT
QUESTIONS. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO OUR SECOND PANEL- YOU KNOW AS
WE CONTINUE TO TACKLE SOME OF
THESE ISSUES AND- TRYING TO WORK
TOGETHER- NOW WE KNOW THAT.
TECHNOLOGY HAS BEEN EVOLVING AND
CHANGING SO OUR SECOND PANEL
WILL FOCUS ON EMERGING
MITIGATION AND RISK MANAGEMENT
TOOLS. AND SO WE WILL HEAR FROM
SOME FOLKS- AT SELECT ONCE AGAIN
THANK YOU TO OUR FIRST PANEL. OF
FIRST UP IN THE SECOND PANEL WE
WILL WANT TO WELCOME MICHAEL
MARTINEZ SENIOR DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER. AND LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. ONCE AGAIN LED BY
COMMISSIONER WE GOT A LOT ON.
OUR MISTER MARTINEZ YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. THREE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO RUBIO.
MORNING EVERYONE BY SURGEONS AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON INSURANCE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR INVITING ME VIRTUALLY HERE
TODAY. AGAIN MIKE MARTINEZ
SERVICE SENIOR DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR HERE ON BEHALF OF
INSURANCE COMMISSION REGARDING A
LOT OF AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE I WAS
ASKED BY THE COMMITTEE TO FOCUS
MY REMARKS ON STEPS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS TAKEN TO INCREASE
THE AVAILABILITY OF INSURANCE
FOR HOMEOWNERS AND BUSINESSES.
INCLUDING PENDING ADMINISTRATIVE
AND REGULATORY ACTIONS IN THE
FACE OF CLIMATE INTENSIFIED.
WILDFIRES I WILL BRIEFLY SHARE
MY SCREEN. M. IT'S. OKAY SO LATE
LAST DECEMBER THE DEPARTMENT
PUBLICLY RELEASED DATA
REPRESENTING APPROXIMATELY
NINETY EIGHT POINT 8% OF THE
HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE MARKET AND
THE STATE THAT CERTAIN INSURANCE
COMPANIES NON RENEWED FEWER.
HOME OWNERS IN TWENTY TWENTY
WHEN COMPARED TO THE PREVIOUS
YEAR OF TWENTY NINETEEN
BASICALLY A 10% DROP IN NON
RENEWAL STATEWIDE. HOWEVER THAT
SAME DATA SHOW THAT THE NUMBER
OF POLICIES WRITTEN BY THE FAIR
PLAN KNOWN AS- THE- NO ES IN THE
STATES INSURER OF LAST RESORT
INCREASED FOR THE SECOND YEAR TO
A NEW HIGH ALTHOUGH THE FAIR
PLAN STILL ONLY REPRESENTS LESS
THAN 3% OF THE OVERALL STATEWIDE
RESIDENTIAL MARKET OF EIGHT
POINT SEVEN MILLION POLICIES
TODAY. FURTHERMORE THIS DATA
ALSO SUGGESTED THAT MANDATORY
HOMEOWNERS MORATORIUM LAW PASSED
BY THE LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY
NINETEEN HAS ALSO HELPED
CONTRIBUTE TO THE OVERALL
DECREASE IN NON RENEWALS. MORE
THAN FOUR MILLION POLICY HOLDERS
HAVE BEEN PROTECTED OVER THE
PAST THREE YEARS UNDER THIS LAW
THAT BANS GENDER LADA. PROBABLY
AUTHORED. PAUL COMMISSIONER LOT
OF BELIEVES WE STILL HAVE A WAY
TO GO AND STILL WE HAVE AN
INSURANCE MARKET THAT IS
AVAILABLE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS.
G. IN THE DEPARTMENT REMAIN
FOCUSED ON A SERIES OF
COMPREHENSIVE INSURANCE
SOLUTIONS TO PROTECT ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND SECURE A
COMPETITIVE INSURANCE MARKET
NAMELY. FIRSTLY PARTNERING WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S ADMINISTRATION TO
CREATE CONSISTENT STATEWIDE HOME
AND COMMUNITY HARDING SAFETY
MEASURES THAT ARE APPLICABLE TO
INSURANCE INCENTIVES. YOU HEARD
FROM MY COLLEAGUE MIKE PETERSON
EARLIER IN THIS HEARING SO I
WILL NOT REPEAT WHAT HE SAID
EXCEPT TO SAY THAT THE WALLS ARE
PARTNERSHIPS SAFER FROM
WILDFIRES FRAMEWORK THAT HE
DESCRIBED BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT. AND THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA HELLO YES WILL
GREATLY HELP INCENTIVIZE BOTH
HOME AND COMMUNITY HARDENING
EFFORTS STATEWIDE. IN ORDER TO
REDUCE LOSSES AND SAVE LIVES.
SECONDLY PUSHING TO INCREASE THE
AVAILABILITY OF INSURANCE
OFFERED BY THE ADMITTED
HOMEOWNERS AND COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE MARKETS. SEVERAL
INSURANCE COMPANIES HAVE
COMMITTED TO THE DEPARTMENT
DURING THE DEPARTMENT'S
ADMINISTRATIVE RATE REVIEW AND
APPROVAL PROCESS THAT THEY WILL
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
HOMEOWNERS AND COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE POLICIES WRITTEN IN
THE STATE. AND CEASE OR LIMIT
NON RENEWALS THESE NEGOTIATIONS
WE BELIEVE HAVE BEEN PRODUCTIVE
TODAY ARE ONGOING AND THE
DEPARTMENT WILL CONTINUE TO
AGGRESSIVELY PUSH FOR MORE NEW
ADMITTED INSURANCE COVERAGE AND
THE TIMING. NOW IN ADDITION TO
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS. THIRDLY
INCREASING INSURANCE COMPANY
RECOGNITION OF MITIGATION
EFFORTS TO PROTECT HOMES
BUSINESSES AND COMMUNITIES. AT
COMMISSIONER LOT IS URGING
INSURANCE COMPANIES HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDED PREMIUM
DISCOUNTS FOR COMMUNITY WIDE AND
HOME SPECIFIC MITIGATION EFFORTS
INCLUDING PROVIDING UP 220%
DISCOUNTS FOR WILDFIRE HARDEN
HOMES. CURRENTLY WE COUNT
SEVENTEEN INSURANCE COMPANIES
AND COUNTING REPRESENTING 40% OF
INSURANCE MARKET PLACE HAVE
ANSWERED THAT COMMISSIONER LET
US CALL TO OFFER DISCOUNTS FOR
SAFER HOMES IN COMMUNITIES WITH
EVEN MORE COMPANIES INTERESTED.
THIS FIGURE IS UP FROM JUST 7%
OF THE MARKET WHEN COMMISSIONER
LOT OF TOOK OFFICE THREE YEARS
AGO. FURTHLY ANNOUNCING NEW
REGULATIONS THAT WOULD IMPROVE
WELFARE SAFETY AND TRANSPARENCY
UNDER THESE PROPOSED REGULATIONS
WHICH COULD BE IN FACT BY THE
END OF THE SUMMER INSURANCE
COMPANIES WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
RECOGNIZE HOMEOWNERS. AND
BUSINESSES SAFETY MEDICAID ACTS
AS AS HOMEOWNERS AND BUSINESSES
WOULD BE ABLE KNOW THEIR WALL
RISK WARS AND BE ABLE TO LOOK
THAT. THESE REGULATE ADDRESS
THAT GERMAN LOT HEARD FROM MANY
AND ACROSS THE STATE- WHEN HE UP
THE DOZEN OF TOWN HALLS- ACROSS
. THAT STEPS BE TAKEN TO
RECOGNIZE THEIR CONSUMERS AND
BUSINESSES EFFORTS TO HARDEN
THEIR PROPERTIES AND COMMUNITIES
AGAINST WILDFIRE WHILE LOWERING
THE RISK OF LOSS AND DAMAGE.
FIFTY MODERNIZING THE FAIR PLAN
KNOWN AS CALIFORNIA'S INSURANCE
SAFETY NET. SO WHAT BETTER MEANS
CONSUMERS AND BUSINESSES
COVERAGE NEEDS. COMMISSIONER
LOTTA ORDER THE FAIR PLAN TO
RAISE ITS COMMERCIAL HOMEOWNERS
COVERAGE LIMITS IN ORDER TO
BETTER SERVE CALIFORNIA'S
BUSINESS USES AND HOMEOWNERS AND
KEEP PACE WITH RISING COST MORE
THAN TWO DECADES. IN ADDITION
GIVEN A RECENT SUPERIOR COURT
DECISIONS COMMISSIONER LAUDED
CONTINUES TO PUSH. THE FAIR PLAN
TO OFFER A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
HOMEOWNER'S POLICY OPTION IN
ADDITION TO ITS CURRENT FIRE
ONLY POLICY COVERAGE IN ORDER TO
MEET CONSUMERS. AND MEDIA
COVERAGE NEEDS. COMMISSIONER
LOTT ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORTED
YOUR- RUBIO'S BILL LAST YEAR
CHAPTER AND ELEVEN AND MADE IT A
HIGH PRIORITY OF THE DEPARTMENT
TO APPROVE THIS NEW COMMERCIAL
COVERAGE TO BE OFFERED TO FARMS
AND AGRICULTURAL BUSINESSES
AFFECTED NOW- LAST MONTH
FEBRUARY FEBRUARY FIRST. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. SIX THREE-
IMPLEMENTING A FIRST OF ITS KIND
CLIMATE INSURANCE REPORT TO ME
CONTAINING FORTY STATE AND LOCAL
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS PUT
TOGETHER BY COMMISSIONER A LOT
AS- CALIFORNIA CLIMATE INSURANCE
WORKING GROUP OVER TWO YEARS
TIME. BUT FOCUS ON REDUCING
DAMAGE AND IMPROVING RECOVERY
FOR VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
FOLLOWING A WILDFIRE IN ADDITION
TO AN EXTREME HEATWAVE OR FIVE
MISTER A LOT OF BELIEVES THAT BY
ACTING NOW. WE CAN SAVE LIVES
AND SAVE COMMUNITIES FROM
INCREASING COSTS HELPING PAXSON
SOCIAL INEQUITIES OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. THESE ACTIONS AMONG.
SEVERAL OTHERS DIED AND HANDING
BIKES MISTER LOTT AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. ARE
NECESSARY TO FURTHER INCREASE
THE AVAILABILITY OF HOMEOWNERS
AND COMMERCIAL INSURANCE ACROSS
THE STATE. ASHLEY HI WILDFIRE
RISK AREAS OVER THE PAST THREE
YEARS. COMMISSIONER LOTTE HAS
HELD MEETINGS WITH BELLS OF
CALIFORNIANS COMMUNITY OR- LOCAL
AND BUSINESS GROUPS MORE THAN
THIRTY SIX COUNTIES. BUILDING ON
AN AREA PUBLIC HERE PUBLIC
FORUMS AND TOWN HALLS SOME OF
WHICH HAVE BEEN HOPE CO HOSTED
WITH MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
IN CLOSING WE AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE INSURANCE AND
COMMISSIONER LANA HOW GREATLY
APPRECIATED YOUR PARTNERSHIP AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
ALL TO CONTINUE ADDRESSING THE
IMPACT OF WILDFIRES AND
INSURANCE AVAILABILITY. ON
CALIFORNIA'S HOMEOWNERS AND
BUSINESSES THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
INVITING ME AGAIN HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU MISS MARTINEZ A PLEASE
THANK THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
AND YOUR TEAM AS WELL I KNOW
THAT YOU'VE BEEN DILIGENTLY
WORKING ON. COLLABORATING WITH
THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY AND I'M
VERY ENCOURAGED BY THE-
DISCOUNTS ALREADY OFFERED AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN CONTINUE TO
PUSH THE ENVELOPE ON THAT FRONT.
OUR NEXT- WE WANT TO TURN IT
OVER TO OUR NEXT PANELIST KAREN
COLLINS ASSISTANT VICE PRESIDENT
OF PERSONAL LINES AMERICAN
PROPERTY CASUALTY INSURANCE
ASSOCIATION WELCOME AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. RIGHT
THANK YOU- YES MY NAME IS KAREN
COLLINS AND I AM THE ASSISTANT
VICE PRESIDENT FOR SCIENCE WITH
THE AMERICAN PROPERTY CASUALTY
INSURER INSURANCE ASSOCIATION OR
AS WE CALL IT THE CIA FOR SHORT.
ALSO A LONGTIME RESIDENT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL. MY
ORGANIZATION A. P. C. I. A. IS
THE NATIONAL TRADE ASSOCIATION
FOR HOME AUTO AND BUSINESS
INSURERS. WE WORK TO PROTECT
PROMOTE PROTECT THE VIABILITY OF
PRIVATE MARKET COMPETITION FOR
THE BENEFIT OF CONSUMERS AND
INSURERS WITH A LEGACY THAT GOES
BACK A HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS. WE
REPRESENT COMPANIES OF ALL SIZES
STRUCTURES AND REGIONS TO
PROTECT FAMILIES COMMUNITIES AND
BUSINESSES IN THE US. AND ALSO
AROUND THE GLOBE. MY COMMENTS
WILL BRIEFLY COVER SOME OF THE
TOOLS ARE INDUSTRY LEVERAGES TO
PROMOTE WILDFIRE MITIGATION. IN
ADDITION TO PROVIDING SOME OF
OUR VIEWS ON THE DEPARTMENT'S
PROPOSED WILDFIRE REGULATION.
FIRST OFF IS THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION WE VIEW ADVOCACY AS
ONE OF OUR GREATEST TOOLS. TO
HELP EDUCATE ON THE CHALLENGES
INSURERS AND CONSUMER SPACE I'M
SORRY TO INTERRUPT FOR JUST ONE
SECOND- WE'RE GONNA PAUSE FOR
JUST ONE SECOND TO GET THE
COMPUTER BACK ON TRACK. CHUCK
WAS REMISS COLLINS WILL LET YOU
KNOW WHEN WE'RE READY.
OKAY. WE ARE SO SORRY FOR THAT
INTERRUPTION WE ARE BACK ON
TRACK YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU
NOT A PROBLEM- AS MENTIONED AS A
TRADE ASSOCIATION WE DO ADVOCACY
AS ONE OF OUR GREATEST TOOLS TO
HELP EDUCATE ON THE CHALLENGES
INSURERS AND CONSUMER SPACE BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY TO OFFER
SOLUTIONS TO PROMOTE A MORE
HEALTHY AND STABLE INSURANCE
MARKET PLACE. OUR ORGANIZATION
IS BEEN VERY ENGAGED IN THE WILD
HEART IN CALIFORNIA OTHER
WESTERN STATES AS WELL AS WITH
FEDERAL AGENCIES AND THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS WHICH IS
THE NATIONAL GOVERNING BODY OF
INSURANCE REGULATORS WE WORK TO
EDUCATE ON THE INCREASING
THREATS OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
DROUGHT ARE WESTERN STATES ARE
FACING IN ADDITION INCREASING
FUEL LOADS IN THE GROWTH OF NEW
COMMUNITIES IN THE WEEK AS THESE
COLLECTIVELY LEAD TO INCREASED
EXPOSURE FOR INSURERS WHICH IN
TURN CAN LEAD TO HIGHER COSTS
FOR CONSUMERS. OUR INDUSTRY'S
BEEN VERY FOCUSED ON WAYS TO
REDUCE RISK THIS INCLUDES MAKING
COMMUNITIES MORE RESILIENT
THROUGH STRONGER AND BETTER
ENFORCE BUILDING CODES INCREASED
OUR IMPROVE RATHER LAND USE
PLANNING RESILIENCE
INFRASTRUCTURE RETROFITTING
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE AND OF
COURSE FUEL REDUCTION IN THE
AREAS MOST AT RISK FOR WILDFIRES
FOR INSURERS RESEARCH HAS BEEN
ANOTHER IMPORTANT TOOL THROUGH
THE INSURANCE INSTITUTE FOR
BUILDING AND HOME SAFETY THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY HAS BEEN AT
THE FOREFRONT OF RESEARCH TO
UNDERSTAND HOW TO MITIGATE
AGAINST WILDFIRE RISK TO REDUCE
FUTURE LOSSES. I'D BE JUST HAS
BEEN A LEADER IN DEVELOPING
SCIENTIFICALLY PROVEN STANDARDS
THAT ENABLE HOMES AND BUSINESSES
TO WITHSTAND WILDFIRES THIS
INCLUDES THEIR SUBURBAN WELFARE
ADAPTATION ROADMAPS WHICH THEY
ROLLED OUT IN TWENTY TWENTY AND
MORE RECENTLY THE FORTHCOMING
WILDFIRE PREPARED HOME
DESIGNATION WHICH WILL BECOME
AVAILABLE THIS SUMMER IN
CALIFORNIA BEFORE EXPANDING TO
OTHER WESTERN STATES THIS
PROGRAM IDENTIFIES A SET OF
REQUISITE MITIGATION ACTIONS
THAT WHEN TAKEN TOGETHER WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE. THE GIVEN
PROPERTIES WILDFIRE RISK. WE
FIRMLY THAT I MORE COME. ARE
HARDENED. THIS SHOULD RESULT IN
A MEANINGFUL DECREASING LOSSES
WHICH SHOULD TRANSLATE TO MORE
AFFORDABLE AND AVAILABLE
COVERAGE FOR CONSUMERS. IN
ADDITION TO RESEARCH TO MITIGATE
THE PHYSICAL RISK YOU MUST FIRST
IDENTIFY THE RISK. NOTHING SURE
IS OFTEN MIGHT LOOK TO THIRD
PARTY VENDORS TO ASSIST IN
IDENTIFYING AND ASSESSING RISK
FOR INDIVIDUAL PROPERTIES.
THROUGH THE UNDERWRITING PROCESS
INSURERS MAY EVALUATE FEATURES
OF THE PROPERTY AND DETERMINE
WHAT CAN AND SHOULD BE MITIGATED
ACCORDING SURE MAY BE ABLE TO
COVER THAT RISK SOME INSURERS
ARE INCREASINGLY LOOKING TO
VIRTUAL TOOLS SUCH AS- PHOTO
BASED INSPECTIONS THAT CAN BE
DONE REMOTELY THROUGH
SMARTPHONES. TO HELP EXPEDITE-
PROVIDE GREATER EFFICIENCIES IN
THESE PROCESSES. A NUMBER OF
INSURERS ARE ALSO BEGINNING TO
OFFER WILDFIRE MITIGATION
SERVICES AS AS PART OF THE
POLICY BENEFITS. THESE SERVICES
MAY BE COORDINATED THROUGH A
THIRD PARTY VENDOR WHICH MIGHT
GO OUT TO A PROPERTY TO HELP
PHYSICALLY REDUCE THE WILDFIRE
EXPOSURE WHEN CERTAIN CONDITIONS
THAT JUST THE THREAT IS
IMMINENT. AND THAT COULD INCLUDE
CLEARING BRUSH REMOVING DEBRIS
OFF OR REMOVED. OFF THE ROOF TO
REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
IGNITION TO THAT PROPERTY. NO
ASIDE FROM REDUCING THE PHYSICAL
RISK INSURERS ARE ALSO WORKING
TO PROVIDE POLICYHOLDERS TOOLS
TO HELP MITIGATE AGAINST
FINANCIAL RISKS. IN OTHER STATES
SOME OF THESE TOOLS INSURANCE
ENCOURAGE INCLUDE HIGHER
CATASTROPHE SPECIFIC DEDUCTIBLES
WHICH CAN LEAD. TO LOWER
PREMIUMS. AND ALSO WORK FOR
DISASTER SAVINGS ACCOUNTS THESE
UNFORTUNATE ARE NOT AVAILABLE TO
CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA AT THIS
TIME THEY WERE. TOLD THAT WE ARE
ADVOCATING. TO PROVIDE. WE HAVE
HOWEVER BEGUN TO SEE IN
CALIFORNIA SOME INSURERS
INCENTIVIZE RISK REDUCTION
THROUGH PREMIUM CREDITS. MORE
INSURERS WOULD LIKE TO OFFER
SIMILAR HOWEVER HAVE BEEN
HESITANT TO DO SO AS THE FRANCE
JUST ISN'T THERE YET. TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THE VARIOUS
WILDFIRE MITIGATION ACTIONS
TRANSLATE INTO DOLLARS. OUR
INDUSTRY IS AGGRESSIVELY WORKING
TO ACTUAL WARILY QUANTIFY THE
VALUE OF WILDFIRE MITIGATION
MEASURES SO INSURERS CAN OFFER
PREMIUM CREDITS WITHOUT OR WITH
CONFIDENCE THAT THEY WILL NOT
RESULT IN ANY UNINTENDED HARM.
THAT DOES UNFORTUNATELY TO
HIGHER RATES. FOR THE PROPOSED
REGULATION FROM THE DEPARTMENT
THIS WOULD BE MAKING IT
MANDATORY FOR INSURERS TO
PROVIDE MEDICATION SENT US
THROUGH THOSE PREMIUM CREDITS.
IN ADDITION TO ALLOWING INSURERS
TO USE WILDFIRE CATASTROPHE
MODELS. YEAH TO BE CLEAR. THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY SHARES THE
SAME GOAL OF CDI TO REDUCE RISK
THREE MEDICATION TO ENCOURAGE A
MORE AFFORDABLE AND AVAILABLE
INSURANCE MARKET AND INSURERS
HAVE BEEN VERY EXTENSIVELY
ENGAGE WITH CD I AND THE OTHER
STATE AGENCIES. THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS TO HELP OFFER EXPERTISE
IN TO FURTHER REFINE THE DRAFT
REGULATION. WOW FAR REALLY IS A
VERY UNIQUE RISK FROM OTHER
CATASTROPHE CATASTROPHE PERILS
SUCH AS MAYBE HURRICANES OR
EARTHQUAKES. AND THAT TO
EFFECTIVELY AND MEANINGFULLY
REDUCE RISK MITIGATION IS
REQUIRED THROUGH BOTH THROUGH
STRUCTURAL ADAPTATION AS WELL AS
THE MANAGEMENT OF FUELS. AND THE
LATTER OF WHICH MUST BE DONE ON
A RECURRING BASIS. ALSO THIS
MEDICATION MUST BE DONE FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL PROPERTY AS WELL AS
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY AS WE
KNOW WIND DRIVEN EMBERS CAN
TRAVEL FROM ONE PROPERTY AND
IGNITE THE NEARBY OR ADJACENT
PROPERTY. CREATING A DOMINO
AFFECT OF LOSSES IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS AS WE'VE SADLY
SEEN IN RECENT YEARS. SO THIS
POSES A VERY UNIQUE CHALLENGE
FOR THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY WHICH
IS THUS FAR FOR ALL THE OTHER
PERILS THAT WE INSURE. THE
INDUSTRY'S ONLY NEEDED TO
ESTABLISH A STANDARD FOCUS ON
HARD BEING A SINGLE HOME WITH
VALIDATION THAT IS A ONE TIME
EVENT. THIS WILDFIRE BREAKS THAT
MOLD REGARDING WHAT THE STANDARD
SHOULD BE AND HOW IT SHOULD BE
VALIDATED. OUR INDUSTRY
CONSISTENTLY. TO THE RESEARCH OF
I. B. H. S. AND WE'RE VERY
PLEASED TO SEE THAT THAT IS
HEAVILY INFLUENCED THE SAFER
FROM WILDFIRES FRAMEWORK.
NOTIFIED FROM THE GAP IN THE
ACTUARIAL DATA NEEDED TO
CREDIBLY SUPPORT PREMIUM
CREDITS- INSURERS HAVE STILL-
SUBMARINE REMAIN CONCERNS WITH
THE REGULATIONS SUCH AS MS
COLLINS I NEED YOU TO START
WRAPPING YOUR COMMENTS UP THANK
YOU. THE THERE IS A SUBSTANTIAL
COSTS FOR INSURERS TO
OPERATIONALIZE MANY OF THESE
REQUIREMENTS ALSO THE BIGGEST
CONCERNS THAT WE CONTINUE TO
RACES THERE'S NO INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY PROTECTIONS PROVIDED TO
INSURERS ARE VENDORS WHICH
EXPENSE SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES TO
DEVELOP NEW AND INNOVATIVE.
MODELS THERE'S A GROWING
CONSENSUS WITH OUR INDUSTRY ON
THE NEED FOR AND BENEFITS
PROVIDED BY RISK MODELS THEY
PROVIDE GREATER UNDERWRITING AND
PRICING PRECISION AND LEAD TO
GREATER STABILITY IN PRICING. SO
WE FIND THAT THERE NEED TO BE A
BALANCE BETWEEN THE PUBLIC
INFORMATION DISCLOSURE AND ALSO
PROTECTING INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
WITH THESE MODEL REVIEWS. WITH
THOSE CONCERNS INSURERS ARE VERY
CONCERNED THAT MOTHERS MAY
HESITATE TO SHARE THE MOST
INNOVATIVE AND SOPHISTICATED
TOOLS IN THE STATE SO WHILE
THESE TOOLS ARE ADVANCING. WE IN
CALIFORNIA MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
LEVERAGE THE FULL BENEFITS THAT
THEY MIGHT BE ABLE TO PROVIDE.
SO TO RECAP THEIR NUMBER OF
TOOLS INSURERS LEVERAGE TO HELP
PROMOTE WILDFIRE RISK REDUCTION
WE ARE APPRECIATIVE OF THE
PROGRESS UNDERWAY IN CALIFORNIA
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU YOU
HAD TO ADDRESS THE SHORTFALLS.
WITHIN THAT PROPOSE REGULATION
OUR PRIMARY GOAL REMAINS TO BE
IDENTIFIED SOLUTIONS TO PROVIDE
MORE AFFORDABLE AND AVAILABLE
INSURANCE COVERAGE. TO HELP
PROTECT WHAT MATTERS MOST WHICH
REALLY IS KEEPING FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME TO. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE PRESENTATION- WE HAVE NOT
HEARD FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE AS WELL AS THE-
INDUSTRY REPRESENTATIVE OB THE
NEXT SECTION AGAIN WE'RE GOING
TO BE FOCUSING ON. SPENDING SOME
TIME LOOKING AT. EMERGING
MITIGATION AND RISK MANAGEMENT
TOOLS AND OTHER- EVOLVING
TECHNOLOGIES SO NEXT I WOULD
LIKE TO WELCOME. A T. LE TOP.
SEAL OF ZESTY A HI. YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
UNTIL A TOP. AND I AM TO SEE-
ZESTY I. WE ARE PRIVATE COMPANY
HEADQUARTERED IN- OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA PLEASE CAN YOU SEE MY
SCREEN. THE YOUR GOD THANK YOU
SO MUCH BYE BYE APOLOGIZE SO WE
ARE A PRIVATE COMPANY
HEADQUARTERED IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA OUR CUSTOMERS ARE
PRIMARILY INSURANCE COMPANIES
AND WE ARE BUILDING ANALYTICAL
MODELS TO UNDERSTAND MODERN
BETTER WEATHER PHENOMENON SUCH
AS WILD FIRES. AS WE HAVE HEARD
FROM MANY PRESENTERS CALIFORNIA
TO DATE IS IN A CRISIS AND WHAT
FIRES ARE SPREADING. JUST I'M
TRYING TO ADVANCE MY SLIDES FOR
SOME REASON YEAH THANK YOU. ON
MY FIRST SPREADING INCREASINGLY
POPULATED AREA US ANY
UNPREDICTED WAYS DRIVING
ECONOMIC LOSSES THAT HAVE
SKYROCKETED OVER THE PAST FIVE
YEARS. I EXPERIENCED THIS MYSELF
WHEN I HAD TO EVACUATE MY OWN
FAMILY FROM NAPA COUNTY AND NAPA
COUNTY IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY. SINCE YOU WON'T BE ABLE
TO STOP EVERY WIDE FIRE FROM
STARTING. AND WE CAN ALWAYS KEEP
HOMES FROM BURNING. HEALTH
INSURANCE MARKET IS NECESSARY TO
BALANCE RISK AND ENABLE PEOPLE
TO PROTECT THEIR PROPERTY.
UNFORTUNATELY THE CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE MARKET IS
NOT HEALTHY TODAY. AND IT'S NOT
HEALTHY BECAUSE WE ARE USING
THIRTY YEAR OLD TOOLS TO
UNDERSTAND A RECENT CHANGE IN
WEATHER PATTERNS. NEW LOSSES AND
RISKS ARE BRINGING THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY TO A BREAKING POINT.
AND IF WE ONLY HAD A DECADES OLD
TOOLS TO FIGHT THIS CRISIS WOULD
PROBABLY LOSE. HOST WOULD BECOME
UNINSURABLE IN MANY PLACES
AROUND CALIFORNIA. MEANING THAT
AN ESTIMATED ONE POINT THREE
TRILLION DOLLARS IN PROPERTY
VALUE WOULD BE AT RISK OF LOSING
AFFORDABLE INSURANCE AND WITH
THAT MORTGAGE FINANCING AS WELL
. THE DEVASTATION FROM THE TOPS
FIRE. ORANGES MY SCREEN DOESN'T
COOPERATE THE DEVASTATION
ROOFTOPS FIRE IN CINEMA COUNTY
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SHOWS%
HOPPER ONLY INCORPORATING
LIMITED REGIONAL VARIABLES SUCH
AS FUEL SLOW AND ACCESS AS AN
IMPORTANT INTEREST MODELS FEELS
TO ACCURATELY PREDICT WHERE
WILDFIRES WILL OCCUR. SO HERE
I'M SHOWING YOU HIGHLIGHTED IN
PURPLE AN AREA OF PREDICTED
WATCHED VIRUS WHICH IS CALLED
THE HIGH FIRE HAZARD ZONES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IN BLUE
I'M SHOWING. OR JUST A- THE
POINT IS THERE IS A MAJOR DELAY
WITH MY SLIDES HERE SORRY FOR
TECHNICAL DETAILS BUT IN BLUE
I'M SHOWING SOME OF THOSE HOMES
THAT WERE DESTROYED BY WILDFIRES
. IN THAT BUT BUT MORE SO MOST
WERE NOT IN THE HIGH FIRE HAZARD
ZONES MORE THAN FIVE THOUSAND
PROPERTIES BURNED TOTALING IN
EXCESS OF NINE BILLION DOLLARS
IN LOSSES IN AREAS PREVIOUSLY
THOUGHT SAFE. THIS LEFT INTEREST
TO PUT THEIR NORMA'S BILL
UNEXPECTED LOSSES. BUT TO DATE
WE HAVE NEW TOOLS TO UNDERSTAND
RISK THANKS TO SIGNIFICANT
ADVANCEMENTS IN TECHNOLOGY OVER
THE PAST DECADE OR SO. SATELLITE
AND AERIAL IMAGERY IS AVAILABLE
FOR THE WHOLE STATE IN HIGH
RESOLUTION. DIG UP MY PROPERTY
ATTRIBUTES LOCAL WEATHER AND
BUILDING PERMITS IS MORE
ACCESSIBLE THAN EVER. AND WITH
THIS DATA WE ARE ABLE TO BUILD
CUTTING EDGE COMPUTER MODELS
THAT CAN CREATE AN UNDERSTANDING
OF THE RISK. BASED ON REAL
LOSSES. NOT OVERLY SIMPLISTIC
ASSUMPTIONS OR SIMULATIONS. OUR
MODELS ARE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND
THE RISK BECAUSE WE HAVE
GATHERED PRE AND POST WHY FIRE
IN THE JURY AS I MENTIONED FROM
SATELLITE AND FROM LOW FLYING
AIRCRAFT SO NOT FROM
INSPECTIONS. AND WE HAVE GAINED
LOST DATA FROM ONE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED HISTORICAL WIDE FIRED
EVENTS MOST OF THEM IN
CALIFORNIA. TO THE BEST OF MY
KNOWLEDGE THIS IS THE LARGEST
WILDFIRE LOSS DATABASE IN THE
INDUSTRY. WE COMPLEMENTED THIS
LOSS DATABASE WITH DATA. WITH A
REAL FIRE SCIENCE FROM
INSTITUTIONS LIKE CAL FIRE AND
ID CHECKS TO MAKE INFORMED
PREDICTIONS OFWHAT WILL MAKE
MORE WHAT WILL MAKE PROPERTIES
MORE OR LESS SUSCEPTIBLE TO LOSS
. BY INCORPORATING SIGNS DO YOU
JUST LIKE OVERHANGING VEGETATION
VEGETATION MULTIPLE DEFENSIBLE
ZONES AS WE HEARD FROM MULTIPLE
SPEAKERS TODAY ROOF MATERIAL
NEIGHBORHOOD DENSITY SMOKE A
PARTIAL USE OF SUPPRESSION AND
MANY MORE. OUR MODEL CAN
DETERMINE WHY FIRE RISKS. ABSENT
OF THE BIAS INTRODUCED BY HUMAN
ANALYSTS WERE INSPECTORS. JUST
REAL FIRES REAL DAMAGE AN
OBSERVABLE PROPERTY FEATURES. SO
WE BUILD A MODEL TO ASSESS RISK
ACROSS TWO DIMENSIONS THE FIRST
ONE IS RISK OF WILDFIRE OR AS
THE INDUSTRY CALLS THE FREQUENCY
THAT'S ORIGINAL SCORE THE
DESCRIBED THE PROBABILITY OF AN
ADDRESS FALLING WITHIN THE WATCH
PARKER METER. THE SECOND ONE IS
RISK OF PROPERTY LOSS OR
SEVERITY. THAT DESCRIBES THE
EXPECTED DAMAGE- ONCE ON ADDRESS
FALLS WITHIN A WIDE FIRE
COMMANDER AND BY THE WAY HIS
SECOND SCORE IS TAKING PROPERTY
SPECIFIC CHARACTERISTICS INTO
CONSIDERATION. SO WE PROCESS ALL
THE SCORES FOR EVERY HOME IN
AMERICA. IN OUR SYSTEMS
DELIVERED A FULLY TRANSPARENT
RESULTS IN LESS THAN ONE SECOND
FOR EVERY PROPERTY. I KNOW IT
WILL START UP CIRCLE STRICKEN
SNYDER INTERJECT I NEED YOU TO
START WRAPPING UP YOUR COMMENTS
YOU HAVE ABOUT THIRTY MORE
SECONDS THANK YOU. YEAH SO I'M
VERY HIGH LEVEL AND ABOUT EIGHTY
PERCENT. OF CALIFORNIA HOMES OR
LOW RISK THE REMAINING HIGH RISK
PROPERTIES ARE THE ONES THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT MUCH MORE CLOSED
AND HERE'S WHERE I WANT TO SHOW
YOU AN EXAMPLE. OPERATE IN. THE
HOLLYWOOD HILLS WHERE ARE THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WAS THE FIRE HAS
HAPPENED. AND THIS IS WHERE
INSURERS ARE NOT. ARE VERY
RELUCTANT TO DO TO WRITE AND-
ADD COVERAGE. IN IF YOU ZOOM IN.
FURTHER AND WE LOOK AT THE
PROPERTY WE CAN SEE THAT WE CAN
PRODUCE AND ANALYSES. THAT IS
RESPONSIVE TO THE EFFECTS OF
COMMUNITY OF PROPERTY SPECIFIC
NEEDED MEDICATION. WE CAN SEE
THAT THIS PROPERTY HAS AMAZING
DEFENSIBLE SPACE HAS MODERN CODE
COMPLIANT BUILDING MATERIALS.
AND IS SEATED ON FLAT LAND SO
EVEN THOUGH THE PROPERTY EXISTS
IN THE ZONE THAT IS HIGH. FOUR
FOOT WIDE VIRUS OUR MODEL CAN
PREDICT ARMADA CAN TRANSPARENTLY
LIST ALL THE REASONS WHY THIS
SHOW WHAT IS HOME SHOULD BE
INSURABLE. I LET ME JUST JUMP TO
THE FINAL COMING HERE WHY SOME
INSURERS ARE LEAVING CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT ACCOUNT FOR
THE NEW RISK OF WILDFIRE. OTHERS
ARE PARTNERING WITH STI TO BE
ABLE TO EXPAND COVERAGE IN
CALIFORNIA. ONE OF OUR PARTNERS
FARMERS INSURANCE IS COMMITTED
TO WRITING ABOUT THIRTY THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL PROPERTIES. THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE NOT HAVE BEEN
WRITTEN BEFORE. AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE IN MY OPENING STATEMENT
WE'RE AN INSURANCE CRISIS. IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO TARGET OUR WRIST
REDUCTION EFFORTS TO HIGH RISK
REGIONS. THIS REQUIRES USING NEW
TOOLS FOR ANALYSIS AND
RECOGNIZING EFFECTIVE ACTIONS
THAT HOME AND BUSINESS OWNERS
CAN TAKE ON THEIR OWN. OUR STATE
LEADERS SHOULD DO ALL THEY CAN
TO ENCOURAGE PROMOTE AND HELP.
ALSO FUN MITIGATION ACTIONS. NOT
OUR HAND INSURANCE SHOULD DO
THEIR PART BY USING INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGY THAT RECOGNIZES
PROPERTY DETAILS KNOWN TO REDUCE
RISK OF LOSS. AND INCORPORATE
THIS LEAK DETAILS IN THE
UNDERWRITING AND RATING PLANS.
THAT TECHNOLOGY IS AVAILABLE
TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU MR TOP TOP
AND NOW. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
FORWARD THANK YOU FOR THAT
INCREDIBLE PRESENTATION- YOU
KNOW THE VISUALS ARE VERY
COMPELLING- WE WILL NOW TURN IT
OVER TO OUR NEXT GUEST JACK
MCCALL FOR EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF LINDSAY. FIRE SENSE
AND WE ARE. RUNNING OUT OF TIME
SO I'M GOING TO ASK THE
PRESENTERS TO KEEP A VERY
CONCISE AS MUCH AS YOU CAN-
MISTER MCCALL WHEN YOU'RE READY
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR REVIEW MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND COMMITTEE
STAFF I APPRECIATE IN WRITING
HERE TODAY TO TALK MY NAME IS
JACK ARE CALLED MUSIC IN A VICE
PRESIDENT WHEN THE FIRE SOUNDS.
OUR COMPANIES BASED IN AS YOU
SAW A PART OF BUT NOT IN CHURCH
DISTRICT. I'D LIKE TO OPEN BY
SAYING THAT THE FIREBIRD
TECHNOLOGY MINUTES TALK ABOUT
HERE WITH THE SAME BATTING
CREDIBLE GROUP ENGINEERS AND
SCIENTISTS THE EXPERIENCE OF THE
ELECTRIC UTILITY INDUSTRY.
DEPLOYMENT VIA T. DEVICES AND
WELFARE DETECTION AND A VERY
EXCITING PROJECT LIKE I. I GO BY
THE END OF THIS YOU'LL YOU'LL
FREE. SO- WHY DO WE- THIS- THIS
NEW TECHNOLOGY- WHILE WORKING AT
THE WORST FIRES IN WORST
WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA WE LOOK
TO CAL FIRE MAINTAINS LISTS OF
THE LARGEST MOST DESTRUCTIVE AND
DEADLIEST WILDFIRES IN THE STATE
YOU CAN SEE THE ALMOST 25% OF
THESE WILDFIRES WERE CAUSED BY
POWER LINES. THIS IS CONSISTENT
WITH RESEARCH THAT SHOWS THAT
WILDFIRES TURN POWER LINES TEND
TO BECOME ABOUT TEN TIMES LARGER
WHEN WILDFIRES STARTED BY OTHER
PRODUCTS THIS IS LARGELY BECAUSE
THE TYPE OF WINDOW ON JUST THE
CAUSE POWER LINE FALLS WERE ALSO
EXTREMELY. EFFECTIVE SPREADING A
MISSILE FIRE. THIS UNIQUE
SITUATION CALLS FOR DEFENSIVE
FIRE DETECTION WHICH CAN DETECT
A WILDFIRE ALMOST IMMEDIATELY
AFTER IGNITION. NO MATTER WHAT
TIME OF DAY. SUCH RAPID
DETECTION CAN REDUCE THE
RESPONSE TIME ENSURING THAT
FIREFIGHTING RESOURCES PROVIDED
THE SMALLEST POSSIBLE FIRE SO
HOW IS THIS DONE TODAY. THERE
ARE SEVERAL EXISTING WILDFIRE
DETECTION SYSTEMS AND PROGRAMS
IN PLACE IN CALIFORNIA AND
AROUND THE WORLD HOWEVER MOST OF
THESE ARE PRIMARILY DESIGNED TO
LOOK OVER EXPANSIVE AREAS AND
STOP WILDFIRES FROM A DISTANCE
MOST COMMONLY BY IDENTIFYING
SMOKE. WHICH MAY LIMIT THE
ABILITY FOR RAPID DETECTION
QUALIFIERS SMALL. IN COMPARISON
THE FIREBIRDS SYSTEM WAS
DESIGNED TO BE PLACED ALONG HIGH
RISK BOUNDARIES AND THEN TO
DETECT AND REPORT A VERY SMALL
WILDFIRES WHICH HER IMMEDIATELY
ADJACENT TO THAT SOUND. AS NOTED
UTILITY POWER LINES ARE A
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT HIGH RISK
I DON'T REDUCE THEIR RECRUITMENT
SOURCE OFTEN SEVERE WILDFIRES.
WITH THE FARMER SYSTEM HAS TWO
PRIMARY FUNCTIONS FIRST THE TECH
WORLD FIGHTERS. SENSORS WITHIN
EACH- FIREBIRD UNIT CAN DETECT
WILDFIRES ACROSS AN ALMOST
THOUSAND FOOT RADIUS RESULTING
IN ABOUT A SIXTY A PROTECTION
ZONE. AND WILDFIRES AS SMALL AS
FIVE BY FIVE FEET IN THE
DETECTED AS FAR OUT AS TWO
HUNDRED FEET AND EVEN SMALLER
FIRES CAN BE DETECTED ON CLOSER
TO ART. THE SECOND FUNCTION OF
THE FIREBIRD IS TO LET PEOPLE
KNOW THAT THERE IS A FIRE. ONCE
DETECTED THE SYSTEM IS DESIGNED
TO NOTIFY INTERESTED PARTIES BY
TEXT OR EMAIL TYPICALLY WITHIN
TWO MINUTES OF DETECTION-
REPLACED AT REGULAR INTERVALS
THE FIBER DEVICES CAN PROVIDE
CONTINUOUS WELFARE DETECTION ONE
SO WITH THE RIGHTS OF WAY. THEY
CAN ALSO BE PLACED ON ANOTHER
CRITICAL BOUNDARY AREAS JUST
ROADWAYS ON. OUR WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE. EACH FIRE PER DEVICE
CONTINUOUSLY MONITORS AND
SURROUNDING AREA USING SIX
WILDFIRES SPECIFIC FORMAL
DETECTORS AND OPTICAL CAMPUS.
USE MULTIPLE UNCONVENTIONAL
NETWORK ALGORITHMS PROCESS IN
EACH UNIT TO MINIMIZE FALSE FOR
MISFIRE DETECTION. THE SYSTEM
ALSO OPERATES THE TIMES NO
PERSONNEL ARE REQUIRED OPERATE
FROM ONE THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
WHEN A SUSPECTED WILDFIRES
DETECTED- EXCUSE ME- OF THE
SYSTEM AUTOMATICALLY NOTIFIES
DESIGNATED PERSONNEL LIKE TEXT
AND EMAIL INCLUDING IMAGES OF
THE SUSPECT THE FIRE.
ELIMINATING THE NEED FOR
DEDICATED CONTROL CENTERS AND
PERSONNEL REDUCES THE COST AND
INCREASES THE SPEED OF
IMPLEMENTATION. ADDITIONALLY THE
FIBER DEVICES ARE SOLAR POWERED
AND CONTAINS NO MEDICATION
FURTHER REDUCING THE TIME AND
COSTS ASSOCIATED. FIREBIRDS OF
MULTIPLE CAMERAS CAN ALSO
PROVIDE DOCUMENTATION THE
OVERLAPPING IMAGES CAMERAS
PROVIDE A 310060 DEGREES VIEW OF
THE SURROUNDING AREA POTENTIALLY
PROVIDING IMPORTANT INFORMATION
REGARDING THE CAUSE OF THE YOUTH
THAT. AS AN ADDED BENEFIT FOR
UTILITIES FIBER DEVICES ALSO
REGULARLY PHOTOGRAPHED A POWER
LINE MORE CONDITIONS THE SYSTEM
INVENTOR BY AUTOMATIC BEFOREHAND
AFTER COMPARISONS TO HELP
UTILITIES DETERMINING DAMAGE
OCCURRED TO THE WIND POWER
WITHOUT. THIS KNOWLEDGE IS VERY
USEFUL WHEN DECIDING WHEN IT'S
POSSIBLE TO SAFELY REENERGIZE A
LINE AFTER PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT OFF. TO HELP BETTER
DEMONSTRATES HOW THE FIREBIRD
BENEFIT THE STATE IN TERMS OF
THE EXAMPLE OF THE REAL WILDFIRE
AND HOW IT'S TIME LINE MAY HAVE
BEEN ALTERED AND FOR YOUR ROOT
SYSTEM AND THE OVAL. AND
DEPLOYED AT THAT TIME. PLEASE
NOTE THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
PROVIDED WITH A COPY OF THIS
PRESENTATION WHICH INCLUDES MORE
DETAILED TIMELINE IT'S COVERED
UP HERE BUT THIS RED BOX. ON THE
ROOF THE TEXT IN THE RED BOX IS
SIMPLIFIED AND LARGE FOR EASIER
VIEWING DURING. SO WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED IN THIS WILDFIRE WAS
THE SIMPLE POWER OUTAGES
REPORTED. THREE AND A HALF HOURS
LATER. A UTILITY WORKER ARRIVED
AT THE SITE REPORTED OUTAGE AND
DISCOVERED THAT THE CAUSE OF THE
FIRE WAS SOME DISTANCE AWAY.
DIFFICULT ROAD CONDITIONS
RESULTED IN THE TAKING AN
ADDITIONAL SIX HOURS FOR THE
WORKERS TO GET AT THE SITE THE
ACTUAL COSTS ON ARRIVING THERE
THE WORKER DISCOVERED. A TREE
LEANING AGAINST THE STILL
PARTIALLY ENERGIZED POWER LINE.
AND THE SMALL FIRE AT THE BASE
OF THE TREE. THERE WAS SOME
COMMUNICATION ISSUES CALIFORNIA
WAS NOT NOTIFIED FORTY FIVE
MINUTES HOWEVER THE- MORE
RESPONSE FROM CAL FIRE'S QUICK
WITH WATER AND FIRE RETARDANT
DROPS STARTING ON FIFTEEN
MINUTES LATER. NOW THIS IS OVER
TEN HOURS AFTER THE INITIAL
REPORT. HOW MUCH. UNFORTUNATELY
A DRONE APPEARS ON THE SITE OF
GROUND AND AIR SUPPORT. FOR THE
TRUNK I AM DRAWN TO PARTS IT'S
DARK INTERESTED PARTIES BROWNING
TOLD THE NEXT DAY. AT THE END OF
THE NEXT DAY THE FARMS TWO
THOUSAND ACRES AND BY THE END OF
THE WEEK. ALMOST A HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES SITES. THE
DIFFERENT FEATURES OF THE
FIREBRAND OF ALL THROUGH THIS
TIMELINE TWO WAYS FIRST SCENARIO
BY EARLY DETECTION THE PHONE
TREE. RECALL THE FIREBIRDS
SYSTEM CAN PROVIDE IMAGES OF THE
POWER LINE. IF THE SYSTEM WERE
IN PLACE THE CHILI COULD HAVE
REQUESTED A SET OF IMAGES OF OUR
LINE EITHER AT THE TIME OUR
RELIGIONS INITIALLY REPORTED
THAT. WORK WHEN UTILITY WORKER
FIRST ARRIVED REALIZED THE CAUSE
OF THE OUTAGE FOR THE WAY. IT
EXAMINATION OF THE IMAGE SHOWED
THE TREE LEANING INTO THE WIND
THE POWER LINE COULD HAVE BEEN
PREEMPTIVELY. BE ENERGIZED
LIKELY PREVENTING. THE SECOND
AND MORE EXPECTED NOTHING FROM
THE SYSTEM ALTERING THE TIMELINE
WOULD HAVE BEEN THROUGH YOUR
DETECTION FIRE. BECAUSE OF THE
COMPLEX NATURE OF THE ACTUAL
FIRES TIMELINE HERE WE ARE ONLY
GOING TO ASSUME THAT THE
FIREBIRDS SYSTEM COULD HAVE
PROVIDED HELLFIRE WITH.
NOTIFICATION ONE HOUR PRIOR TO
WHEN THE- ASSUMING ALL OF THE
OTHER EVENTS IN THE TIMELINE IN
SEQUENCE G. DIFFERENCE NOW IS
THAT WHEN THE DRONE DEPARTS
THERE IS STILL ONE OF OUR DAILY
. CAL FIRE OFFICIALS QUOTED
AFTER THE ACTUAL FIRE WE BELIEVE
MERCHANTS IN RESPOND RISK
ACTIVELY CONTROL THE FIRE ONE TO
TWO ACRES WITH THE ADDITIONAL
TIME THEY WERE ROBBED OF DUE TO
THE DRONE NOT ALLOWING
RESUMPTION- SUPPORT. ALL HERE WE
SEE THE DEPLOYMENT OF THE
FIREBIRDS SYSTEM PROVED TO BE
PROVIDED AT LEAST TWO
OPPORTUNITIES TO EITHER HAVE
PREVENTED THE FIRE FROM
STARTING. OR TO CONTROL THE FIRE
BY PROVIDING ADDITIONAL TIME
ROUTINES. IN SUMMARY THE
FIREBIRD WILDFIRE DETECTION
SYSTEM OVER HE PROBABILITIES
DESIGNED SPECIFICALLY TO ADDRESS
THE CHALLENGES OF DETECTING
WILDFIRES WHICH OCCUR ALONG
POWER LINES. ALL DEPLOYMENT OF
THE SYSTEM SHOULD. REDUCE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF SMALL WILDFIRES
FROM GOING UNNOTICED REDUCE THE
FIREFIGHTING RESOURCES NEEDED TO
CONTROL THE SMALLER AMOUNT.
REDUCED PROPERTY DAMAGE REDUCE
THE LOSS OF LIFE INCREASE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND IF NEED AND IF
NECESSARY INCREASED TIME FOR YOU
WHICH I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND ATTENTION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY MISTER
MCCALL- EVERY SHAPE THE TIME
SPENT HERE NEXT WE WILL MOVE ON
TO. OUR NEXT PRESENTER RANDY
**** GENERAL COUNSEL FOR
WILDFIRE DEFENSE SYSTEMS MR
CLARK THING READY YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE GERMAN RUBIO
ASSISTANT- SHARED JONES. I AM
GOING. TO THIS STARTED- THERE WE
GO OKAY SO- MY NAME IS RANDY
**** I AM A CO FOUNDER EXECUTIVE
VICE PRESIDENT GENERAL COUNSEL
OF WILDFIRE DEFENSE SYSTEMS WITH
ITS PRINCIPAL OFFICE IN BOZEMAN
MONTANA- SIMPLY STATED W. E. S.
CONTRACTS WITH INSURERS TO SAVE
HOUSES FROM RAVAGES A WILDFIRE
IN RETURN FAMILIES TO THEIR
HOMES ITS SERVICES ARE PAID FOR
ENTIRELY BY INSURERS AND COMES
WITHOUT COST TO HOMEOWNERS OR TO
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS I THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW OUR
CONTRIBUTIONS WITH SUCH A-
LEARNER. AND DISTINGUISHED PANEL
. THE EASIEST WAY TO PUT THIS
INTO PERSPECTIVE IS TO TAKE AN
ALL TOO COMMON SCENARIO IN
CALIFORNIA IMAGINE A HOUSE
PERHAPS IN A BEAUTIFUL WOODED
SETTING. THERE'S A FIRE
THREATENING THE OCCUPANTS ARE
ANXIOUSLY WATCHING GATHERING UP
ITEMS IMPORTANT PAPERS
PHOTOGRAPHS- WHAT ARE WE GOING
TO TAKE THERE'S AN EVACUATION
ORDER. HAT'S IMPORTANT PAPERS
PHOTOS WHATEVER THEY DECIDE IT
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT ARE LEFT
BEHIND. AND THESE ARE ANXIOUS
AND FRIGHTENING TIMES BUT IF THE
HOME IS INSURED BY A COMPANY
CONTRACTED WITH WTS. WE'VE
ALREADY BEEN TRACKING THAT FAR
DOING THREAT ASSESSMENTS IN PRE
POSITIONING RESOURCES TO TAKE
MITIGATION STEPS TO PROTECT THE
HOME. ONCE WE SET FOOT ON A
PROPERTY IN TAKE MITIGATION
STEPS THERE PHYSICALLY ON THE
PROPERTY THERE IS A 99% CHANCE
THAT THAT PROPERTY WILL SURVIVE.
WHICH MAKES US HAPPY WHEN WE SEE
IT THAT WE WERE ABLE TO SAVE
SOMEONE'S HOME AND ARE GRATEFUL
FOR IT OF COURSE. SO WHAT IS
THIS COMPANY THAT- THAT DOES
THIS WORK. IT IS WILDFIRE
DEFENSE SYSTEMS IT WAS IN IN IT
WAS STARTED BY MY PARTNER DAVID
TORGERSON HE INVENTED THE
QUALIFIED INSURANCE RESOURCE
BUSINESS SOME FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
AND I'VE BEEN PLEASED TO WORK
WITH HIM. WE'RE NOT THE ONLY
COMPANY THAT DOES THIS SORT OF
WORK BUT WE ARE- THE LARGEST AND
MOST EXPERIENCED AND ALL EXPLAIN
. AS YOU CAN SEE YOU WE ARE THE
THIRD LARGEST WILDFIRE AGENCY
AFTER THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- WE ARE
WE ARE NOT SMOKE CHASERS WE'RE
NOT TWO GUYS IN A TRUCK WE'RE
NOT PRIVATE FIREFIGHTERS ABOUT
AVAILABLE FOR HIRE BY WEALTHY
CLIENTS NO PRIVATE INDIVIDUAL
CAN HIRE US WE SERVE THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY ONLY AND
STRONGLY FAVOR SPECIFIC
QUALIFICATIONS AND PROTOCOLS FOR
QUALIFIED INSURANCE RESOURCES
WORKING WITHIN THE- EVACUATIONS
ON. WHAT WE DO IS SIMPLY THIS.
BUT LET'S BE CLEAR IF YOUR HOUSE
IS IN THE WRONG PLACE THE FIRES
GOING OVER THE TOP OF IT THERE'S
NOTHING THAT ANYONE CAN DO TO
STOP IT MOST STRUCTURES BURNED
BECAUSE MEMBERS IN HEAT AND
THAT'S WHAT WE HELP PROTECT
AGAINST WE DON'T FIGHT FIRE ON
THE FRONT LINES WE DON'T LIGHT
BACKFIRES NONE OF THAT IS OUR
MISSION WE'RE SUPPLEMENTAL TO
THE TRADITIONAL FIRE SERVICE
WITH A FOCUS ENTIRELY ON
MITIGATION ACTIONS. HERE'S SOME
YOU CAN READ THESE FOR YOURSELF
BUT HERE'S BUT THERE ARE SOME
THAT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT IN
PARTICULAR- ALL OF OUR CLIENTS
ARE INSURERS MOST OF THE TOP TEN
PROPERTY AND CASUALTY CARRIERS.
AND MANY SMALLER INSURERS. AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER OUR SERVICE
COMES WITHOUT COST IT'S PART OF
THE INSURANCE POLICY. NO
ADDITIONAL PREMIUM COST. OF
SECOND OUR CREWS ARE UNION CREWS
ALL FULLY QUALIFIED- THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
FIREFIGHTERS CREWS. WE ARE A
SUPPLEMENT TO PRIVATE FIRE
RESPONSE AND WE AND WHEN WE ARE
ON A FIRE WE INTEGRATE INTO THE
INCIDENT COMMAND STRUCTURE ON
FIRE. LAST YEAR ON DIXIE ON CAL
OR WE WERE THEY'RE BRINGING TO
BEAR HUNDREDS OF FIRE
PROFESSIONALS AND DOZENS UPON
DOZENS OF FULLY QUALIFIED- FULLY
OUTFITTED- LIAISON VEHICLES FIRE
VEHICLES. INCLUDING TENDERS AND
TRUCKS AS WELL AS HAND CREWS.
THIS IS OUR MISSION- WE TEACH
OUR PEOPLE DO THINK LIKE EMBERS
AND BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT STARTS
MOST FIRED WE SHOP AHEAD OF AND
AFTER THE- THE FOURTH AT THE
FRONT OF THE FIRE TAKING STEPS
AS SOME AS SIMPLE AS- BLOWING
OUT GUTTERS AND REMOVING DECK
FURNITURE ALL THE WAY UP TO
SETTING UP SPRINKLER SYSTEMS
IMPLYING RETARDANT OR FIRE
BLOCKING GEL IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT I MAKE A POINT ABOUT FIRE
RETARDANT BLOCKING GEL WE USE NO
P. FOSTER OTHER CHEMICALS THAT
CAN CAUSE. RISK OF HARM TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE PEOPLE OR ANY
PEOPLE OR TO THE ENVIRONMENT.
OUR PRODUCTS MEET OR EXCEED
STANDARDS NECESSARY TO BE LISTED
ON THE QUALIFIED PRODUCTS LIST
OF THE UNITED STATES FOREST
SERVICE. YOU CAN SEE HERE. WE
ARE BASED IN BOZEMAN WE'RE IN
COLORADO OREGON IDAHO- WITH A
STRONG PRESENCE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE EMPLOYED DOZENS OF PEOPLE
ASSIGNING CALIFORNIAN PAY
LITERALLY MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TAX ON AN ANNUAL BASIS IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS A PICTURE OF
A PORTION OF OUR EMERGENCY
COORDINATION CENTER- FROM THIS
ROOM WE TRACK EVERY FIRE OF
SIGNIFICANCE IN THE WESTERN
UNITED STATES TRYING ON FEDERAL
AND STATE RESOURCES RESOURCES
BUT ALSO OUR OWN FIRE SPECIALS.
THIS ALLOWS US TO MOVE TRUCKS
AND PERSONNEL ALL OF OUR
VEHICLES HAVE GPS TRACKING IN
OUR LIVE ON THE SYSTEM KNOWN AS
SCOUT. BY INCIDENT COMMAND ON
CALIFORNIA FIRES. I WANT TO MOVE
QUICKLY TO- THE RESULTS BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT MATTERS DID YOU CAN
SEE HERE WE'VE GOT- OOPS I WENT
TOO FAR WE NEED TO GO BACK.
THERE WE GO- LAST YEAR IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IN CALIFORNIA WE SET
FOOT ON IN AND TOOK MITIGATION
STEPS ON JUST SHORT OF SEVEN
THOUSAND HOMES. IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. WE WORK WE EXPECT TO BE
ABLE WE WILL BE SCALED UP TO AND
BE ABLE TO SET FOOT ON. TWO
THOUSAND HOMES A WEEK SO IN A
LINK THE FIRE SEASON. PERHAPS AS
MANY AS TWENTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA HOMES- WE PHYSICALLY
SET FOOT ON BECAUSE THAT'S THE
REAL KEY. WILL STAFF OVER SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND HOURS WORKED BY
W. D. S- YOU. IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO CLEARLY DEALING WITH CAT WITH
WILDFIRE IS A DIFFICULT PROBLEM-
THE RIPPLE EFFECTS ON INSURANCE
INSURANCE AFFORDABILITY AND
AVAILABILITY- IS A MULTI FACETED
PROBLEM. ALL OF OUR INSURANCE
RESOURCES LIKE W. E. S. ARE NOT
THE ONLY ANSWER OF COURSE BUT WE
BELIEVE WE ARE A MAJOR
CONTRIBUTOR TO SAVING CALIFORNIA
PROPERTY. OF ONE HOUSE AT A TIME
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK WITH YOU AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR **** WROTE FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION- WE HAVE- ONE MORE
WHICH WILL BE COMBINED AS ONE
REMIND THE NEXT PRESENTERS
YOU'LL HAVE. COMBINED TIME OF US
SEVEN MINUTES SO- I WILL START
WITH KATIE SOBEL MANAGING
DIRECTOR. A. ON PUBLIC SECTOR
SECTOR PARTNERSHIP. WHEN YOU'RE
READY YOU MAY PROCEED. AFTER
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY AND THANK YOU TO
OUR FELLOW PRESENTERS WE WILL
KEEP OUR COMMENT SHORT. MY NAME
IS KATIE STABLE AND OUR STATE
AND LOCAL PRACTICE GROUP FOR
ENHANCED PUBLIC SECTOR
PARTNERSHIP AND JOINING ME IS MY
CALLING MITCHELL ROSENBERG.
MANAGING DIRECTOR FOR ANZ
SECURITIES. PER FORTY YEARS AND
HAS SUPPORTED RISK MANAGEMENT
STRATEGIES FOR PUBLIC ENTITIES
INCLUDING MORE THAN HALF THE US
STATES OVER A HUNDRED LARGE
MUNICIPAL GOVERNMENTS AND DOZENS
OF LARGE. THE LARGEST
TRANSPORTATION PUBLIC UTILITY
AUTHORITIES. IN A FEW MINUTES WE
HAVE TODAY MENTIONED I WILL
BRIEFLY DISCUSS PARAMETRIC
PRODUCTS AND HIGHLIGHT HOW
THEY'RE BEING USED ESPECIALLY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
WILDFIRES. BY THE LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND POWER.
WHEN YOU MANAGE COVERAGE THERE
ARE TWO MAIN WAYS TO STRUCTURE
HOW INSURANCE RECOVERIES ARE
RECEIVED BY A POLICYHOLDER. THE
FIRST AND MOST WIDELY KNOWN
AREN'T THAT MANY PRODUCTS. WHICH
PROVIDE INSURANCE COVERAGE WHEN
AN ACTUAL DOLLAR LOSS OCCURS
OFTEN DUE TO PHYSICAL DAMAGE.
THIS IS TYPICALLY HOW IN A
HOMEOWNERS OR CAR INSURANCE
POLICIES DRAFTED WHERE IF AN
EVENT OCCURS A CLAIM IS FILED.
INSURE CONFIRMS THAT THE
DEDUCTIBLE IS MET OUR CLAIMS
ADJUDICATION PROCESS IS
COMPLETED AND THEN THE INSURED
RECEIVED. THE SECOND IS
PARAMETRIC BASED OUR PRODUCTS DO
NOT REQUIRE DEDUCTIBLE AND
RECOVERIES ARE NOT I DO NOT HAVE
TO BE KIND OF PHYSICAL DAMAGE
FOR AN ACTUAL DOLLAR LOSS
INSTEAD A PRESET AMOUNT OF
INSURANCE IS PAID OUT WHEN A PRE
AGREED THAT THAT OCCURS. THE
SECOND YEAR A WILDFIRE BURNING A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF ACRES RAINFALL
OR STORM SURGE OR OVER A CERTAIN
LEVEL AS IS THE CASE WITH THE
NEW YORK METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY. MR
BAROMETRIC PRESSURE OF A
HURRICANE AS IS THE CASE FOR THE
GOVERNMENT OF JAMAICA OR AN
EARTHQUAKE OF A CERTAIN
MAGNITUDE AS IS THE. ASE FOR
BLACKSTONE CALIFORNIA. THERE ARE
TWO CLEAR BY OF PARAMETRIC
INSURANCE THE FIRST IS HOW
QUICKLY THE INSURANCE RECOVERIES
ARE PAID OUT. OFTEN IN DAYS OR
WEEKS COMPARED TO ADANI
PRODUCTS. AND THE SECOND IS THAT
PARAMETRIC COVERAGE IS OFTEN
USED TO FILL INSURED. UNDER
INSURED AND UNINSURED PROTECTION
GAPS ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT
ACCOMPANY PRODUCTS NOT SUCH AS
RECOVERIES FOR FINANCIAL OR
BUDGETARY LOSSES. WHEN THERE'S
NO ACTUAL PHYSICAL DAMAGE SUCH
AS A BUSINESS OR SERVICE
INTERRUPTION. ALTHOUGH THE
OUTSIDE OF THE PARAMETRIC
PRODUCT IS BROADER COVERAGE AND
MORE ©EDIACY
POTENTIAL CONCERN IS STRUCTURING
A SOLUTION TO AVOID WHAT THEY
CALL AN INVEST ACTORS. WHERE THE
INSURED EXPERIENCES A
CATASTROPHIC EVENT THAT DOES NOT
MEET THE PRE AGREED PARAMETERS
COVERAGE. IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT WORKING WITH A
QUALIFIED PARTNER WHO HAS
EXPERIENCE NOT ONLY STRUCTURAL
PARAMETRIC PRODUCTS. BUT WHO
ALSO HAS ACCESS TO MULTIPLE
MARKETS IT'S CRITICAL TO REDUCE
US MESS ACTORS. GREAT
COMPETITION AND PRICING AND
DRIVE TRANSPARENCY. WHEN USED
CORRECTLY PARAMETRIC COVERAGE IS
USED TO COMPLEMENT NOT REPLACE
SELF INSURANCE INTERNET COVERAGE
AND REALLY IT SHOULD BE THOUGHT
OF AS JUST ANOTHER TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX. WELL THERE ARE A FEW
DIFFERENT EXAMPLES TO SHARE
INCLUDING THE WORLD BANK NEW
YORK METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY AND THE GOVERNMENT
JAMAICA. WE THOUGHT IT MAY BE
HELPFUL TO HIGHLIGHT THE LOS
ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF POWER AND
WATER. WHICH CURRENTLY COVERED
BY A PARAMETRIC PRODUCT FOR
WILDFIRE. LAST YEAR AND CREATED
THE FIRST WILDFIRE PARAMETRIC
CASH CASH BOND. WITH FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF INSURANCE
PROTECTION FOR LA DEPARTMENT OF.
WATER AND POWER. OUR OBJECTIVE
WAS TO USE RISK MANAGEMENT
STRATEGIES TO ENHANCE. THEIR
DISASTER RISK MANAGEMENT
APPROACH TO CLOSE THAT. GAP I
CAN'T COMPROMISE L. A. D. W. P.
WITH COVERAGE ON A PARAMETRIC
BASED S. TIED TO A WILDFIRE
BURNING IN A SPECIFIC LOCATION.
THIS WAS THE FIRST CAP ON
GLOBALLY TO BENEFIT A MENISCAL
UTILITY ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD.
PRODUCT WAS AWARDED BOTH THE
TRADING REST NOW MIGHT
TRANSACTION OF THE YEAR AND THE
INSURANCE INSIDER'S REINSURANCE
TRANSACTION OF THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. IN CLOSING WITH A
FOUR TO CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS ON
HOW BEST TO THINK ABOUT- METRIC
PRODUCTS TO COMBAT INSURED.
UNDER INSURED AND UNINSURED
ACTION ACTION GAPS TO PROTECT
PROTECT AGAINST KNOWN AND
UNKNOWN EMERGING RESEARCH AS
CLIMATE CHANGE AND NATURAL
DISASTERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH KATIE ARE NOW
TURN IT OVER TO MR ROSENBERG YOU
MAY PROCEED. MANAGER WE'RE
TOGETHER SO THAT WAS OUR PRESS
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APPRECIATE HOW CONCISE YOU WERE
I WANT TO NOW TURN IT OVER TO
MEMBERS AND THEY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. MISTER ROGER LADA YOU
MAY PROCEED. SOMEONE GET HIS
MICROPHONE PLEASE TESTING
TESTING THERE IS OKAY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- FOR GREAT. MEETING
TODAY GETTING ALL THE
INFORMATION- FROM THE INSURANCE
I'D LIKE TO GO FROM THE INITIAL
INSURANCE INDUSTRY IN A IN A
SPECIAL I'D LIKE TO GIVE A SHOUT
OUT TO- MISS MARTINEZ FROM- ARE-
COMMISSIONER LAWRENCE OFFICE AND
I'M EXCITED TO HEAR THAT. HIS
FIGHT FOR THE CALIFORNIA FAIR
PLAN THAT IT EXTENDS BEYOND FIRE
ONLY PLEASE CONTINUE THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE THE FIRE- THE- FAIR
PLANNED TO GO AHEAD AND COVER
COMMERCIAL HOMEOWNERS AT A
LIGHT. AND ALSO. I'D LIKE TO
MAKE IT SHORT BUT- WHAT IS IT-
THE BURIAL AND ONE OF THE LAST
SPEAKERS THAT THE FIRE
MITIGATION AND- W. W. DS WHO-
WHO GO IN AFTER THE FIRES AND- I
AM SURE WORK WITH THE
HOMEOWNERS. TO CLEAN UP- THE
FIRE AREAS AND SO ON WHEN THEY
COME BACK AT LEAST A GOOD FIND-
SOME SENSE OF WHERE THEIR HOMES
WERE IN IT'S A TERRIBLE TERRIBLE
THING BUT- THANK YOU FOR THEM
AND EVERYONE WHO- CABEY FORCE
TODAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. FOR
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER. THANK YOU
MR ARCHULETA. SEE NO INTEREST I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF OUR
PRISONERS- IT'S REALLY
INTERESTING WHEN WE START SEEING
THE DATA I WAS. REALLY SORT OF
IMPRESSED BY I BELIEVE IT WAS MR
TOPS PRESENTATION AND IT REALLY
CLEARLY SHOWS HOW. ARE FROM
TWENTY TEN TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THE FIRES. CONTINUE TO GET MORE
DEADLY MORE DEVASTATING AND SO
I'M REALLY ENCOURAGED TO SEE HOW
EVERYONE'S COMING TOGETHER. TO
NOT ONLY COLLABORATE BUT
COMPLEMENT THE WORK THAT EACH
ORGANIZATION HAS JOINED. US SO
ONCE AGAIN I WANT TO THANK ALL
OF YOU THAT CAME HERE TODAY I
KNOW THEY WERE RUNNING OUT OF
TIME AND FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT
PUT UP WITH MY RASPY VOICE TODAY
I WANT TO THANK YOU. ON THAT
THANK YOU TO THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER AND EVERYONE ELSE-
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO MONITOR NEW
TECHNOLOGIES THAT AGAIN
COMPLEMENT THE EFFORTS OF
EVERYTHING THAT CALIFORNIA. AND
IN OUR LEGISLATURE IS CHEWING
FELT THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN SO NOW
WE WILL TURN IT OVER TO TOP
PUBLIC COMMENT SO AT THIS POINT
I WILL ASK. THAT OUR MODERATOR.
QUEUE UP THE SPEAKERS. CAN YOU
PLEASE GIVE UP AND ONCE THEY GET
THEIR QUEUE PLEASE GIVE ME THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF SPEAKERS WAITING
ON THE LINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOU FOR PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ONE
ZERO FOR ANY PUBLIC COMMENT. AND
MEDICARE WE HAVE NO PUBLIC
COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I'M JUST GONNA ALLOW YOU TO
ASK ONE MORE TIME TO MAKE SURE
WE DON'T MISS ANYONE. SURE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOR ANY PUBLIC COMMENT. AND WE HAVE NO PUBLIC COMMENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MODERATOR
AND ONCE AGAIN I WANNA THANK
EVERYONE TO JOIN US HERE TODAY
ON ALL THE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS- THIS CONVERSATION
HIGHLIGHTS HOW FAR OUR
COLLECTIVE EFFORTS HAVE COME.
OUT IN A JOINT EFFORT ESPECIALLY
THE LAST FEW YEARS- AS STATED AS
ONE OF THE PANELISTS THAT LAST
YEAR THERE WAS ONE OF THE
LARGEST INVESTMENTS MADE IN
CALIFORNIA AS A PERTAINS TO
TACKLING THE WILDFIRES AND AS WE
KNOW THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT THE
LOSS OF LIFE THE LOSS OF
PROPERTY. BUT THE TRAUMA TO
FAMILIES THAT CONTINUE FOR
GENERATIONS TO CONSOLE ONCE
AGAIN I'M REALLY ENCOURAGED TO
SEE THAT ALL THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER OUT IT GOT A LOT OF
GUYS BEEN WORKING WITH OUR
INSURANCE INDUSTRY AND NOW
THEY'RE ACCEPTING INDIVIDUAL-
NOT ONLY OFFERING INCENTIVES BY
GIVING CREDIT THAT'S WELL AND I
HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS. FOR ALL THE
COMPANIES THAT SHARED SOME OF
THE NEW TECHNOLOGIES ONCE AGAIN
WE WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR SO
HOPEFULLY WE CAN AT SOME POINT
IN THE NEAR FUTURE FACE THE MORE
LIVES AND PROPERTY SO THANK YOU
ALL OF YOU- AND TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING OR JUST LISTENING
REMOTELY WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. I IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE OP
PLEASE SUBMIT COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING YOUR
COMMENTS ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND
WE RECOGNIZE SOMETIMES THERE ARE
TECHNOLOGY CHALLENGES SO WE
WANNA HEAR FROM YOU. PLEASE GO
TO OUR WEBSITE AND MAKE SURE
THAT YOUR TESTIMONY IS UP
OFFICIALLY RECORDED SO THANK YOU
AND- THIS A SENATE COMMITTEE
HEARING. IS NOW ADJOURNED HAVE A
WONDERFUL DAY. THANK YOU.